bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission décrypteront
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau nos reporters sur le
terrain
un seul titre ce soir édition consacrée
à la crise du coronavirus emmanuel
mettront va s'adresser dans quelques
instants aux français sur cette crise
sanitaire
une allocution solennelle pour annoncer
la suite des événements est peut-être le
passage un stade iii les opérations
chirurgicales non urgentes sont d'ores
et déjà déprogrammée selon les autorités
sanitaires
le chef de l'état qui s'exprime
suite et on écoute et voilà on écoutera
donc emmanuel macron dans quelques
instants me dit on emmanuel macron à
l'elysée eh bien on va donc écouté le
chef de l'état dans quelques instants en
attendant mes invités gilles casanova
consultant en stratégie et communication
à ses côtés yves buisson membre de
l'académie de médecine bonsoir à tous
les deux emmanuel macron dont on pensait
qu'ils étaient là mais il n'est pas là
il va pas tarder évidemment à s'exprimer
qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre gilles
casanova leur semble grave c'est comme
si le cours des choses s'étaient
accélérées ces dernières secondes
ce n'est probablement pas sur le plan
médical que le chef de l'état va être le
plus capable de répondre aux français
mais notamment dans un domaine qui est
celui de la vie les entreprises qui est
déjà très impacté par la chute d'une
série d'activités qui dont les touches
chômage partiel déjà élevé chômage
technique est là peut-être aura-t-il
l'occasion d'expliquer un dispositif
d'autant que cela est coordonnée avec
une crise boursière qui a été amené par
la crise de l'opep et la chute des prix
du pétrole mais qui redouble ans le
phénomène du coronavirus créé une
situation qui demande de manière assez
naturelle que les pouvoirs publics
s'exprime sur ce qu'ils peuvent faire
pour essayer de
de dison d'amenuiser les impacts de ce
côté là et puis du côté santé il
annoncera peut-être des décisions mais
que nous ne connaissons pas ils lui sont
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse de
héros ou alors qu'on écoute
effectivement le président n'arrête plus
vives
[Musique]
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes depuis quelques
semaines notre pays fait face à la
propagation d'un virus
le coc vide 19 qui a touché plusieurs
milliers de nos compatriotes
j'ai bien entendu ce soir avant toute
chose une pensée émue et chaleureuse
pour les familles et les proches de nos
victimes
cette épidémie qui affecte tous les
continents et frappe tous les pays
européens et la plus grave crise
sanitaire qui est connue la france
depuis un siècle
dans l'immense majorité des cas le coc
vite 19 et sans danger mais le virus
peut avoir des conséquences très graves
en particulier pour celles et ceux de
nos compatriotes qui sont âgés ou
affectés par des maladies chroniques
comme le diabète l'obésité ou le cancer
durant plusieurs semaines
nous avons préparé à j les personnels
des hôpitaux médecins infirmiers
ambulanciers les agents des samu de nos
hôpitaux les médecins de ville
l'ensemble des personnels du service
public de la santé en france sont
engagés avec dévouement et efficacité
si nous avons pu retarder la propagation
du virus et limiter les cas sévères
c'est grâce à eux
parce que tous ont répondu présent tous
ont accepté de prendre du temps sur leur
vie personnelle familiale pour notre
santé c'est pourquoi en votre nom
je tiens avant toute chose à exprimer ce
soir la reconnaissance de la nation à
ses héros en blouse blanche
ces milliers de femmes et d'hommes
admirable qui n'ont d'autre boussole que
le soin d'autres préoccupations que
l'humain notre bien-être notre vie tout
simplement
je veux aussi ce soir salué le sang
froid dont vous avez fait preuve face à
la propagation du virus
vous avez pu ressentir pour vous même
pour vos proches de l'inquiétude voire
de l' angoisse et c'est bien légitime
tous vous avez su faire face en ne
cédant ni à la colère ni à la panique
mieux en adoptant les bons gestes vous
avait ralenti la diffusion du virus et
ainsi permis à nos hôpitaux et nos
soignants de mieux se préparer c'est
cela une grande nation des femmes et des
hommes capables de placer l'intérêt
collectif au dessus de tout une
communauté humaine qui tient par des
valeurs la solidarité la fraternité
cependant mes chers compatriotes je vais
vous le dire ce soir avec beaucoup de
gravité de lucidité mais aussi la
volonté collective que nous adoptions la
bonne organisation
nous ne sommes qu'au début de cette
épidémie est partout en europe
elle s'accélère elle s'intensifie face à
cela la priorité absolue pour notre
nation sera notre santé je ne
transigerai sur rien et un principe nous
guide pour définir nos actions il nous
guide depuis le début pour anticiper
cette crise puis pour la gérer depuis
plusieurs semaines et il doit continuer
de le faire c'est la confiance dans la
science c'est d'écouter celles et ceux
qui savent les plus grands spécialistes
européens se sont exprimés ce matin dans
une publication importante
j'ai réuni aujourd'hui avec le premier
ministre le ministre de la santé
notre comité scientifique de suivi nous
avons en france les meilleurs virologues
les meilleurs épidémiologistes des
spécialistes de grand renom des
cliniciens aussi des gens qui sont sur
le terrain et que nous avons écouté
comme nous faisons depuis le premier
jour tous nous ont dit que malgré nos
efforts pour le freiner le virus
continue de se propager et est en train
de s'accélérer
nous le savions nous le redoutions ce
qui risque de se passer c'est que la
maladie touchera d'abord les personnes
les plus vulnérables
beaucoup d'entre eux auront besoin de
soins adaptés à l'hôpital souvent
d'assistance respiratoire
c'est pourquoi j'y reviendrai dans un
instant nous prenons des mesures très
fortes pour augmenter massivement nos
capacités d'accueil à l'hôpital car
l'enjeu est de continuer a aussi soigné
les autres maladies c'est aussi de se
préparer à une possible deuxième vague
qui touchera un peu plus tard en nombre
beaucoup plus réduit des personnes plus
jeunes
a priori moins exposés à la maladie mais
qu'il faudra soigner également dans ce
contexte
l'urgence est de protéger nos
compatriotes les plus vulnérables et
l'urgence est de freiner l'épidémie
afin de protéger nos hôpitaux nos
services d'urgence et de réanimation nos
soignants qui vont avoir à traiter comme
je viens de vous l'expliquer de plus en
plus de patients atteints ce sont là nos
priorités c'est pour cela qu'il nous
faut continuer de gagner du temps et
suivre celles et ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles protéger les plus vulnérables
d'abord c'est la priorité absolue c'est
pourquoi je demande ce soir à toutes les
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans à
celles et ceux qui souffrent de maladie
chronique ou de troubles respiratoires
aux personnes en situation de handicap
de rester autant que possible à leur
domicile elles pourront bien sûr sortir
de chez elle pour faire leurs courses
pour s'aérer
mais elles doivent limiter leurs
contacts au maximum dans ce contexte
j'ai interrogé les scientifiques sur nos
élections municipales dont le premier
tour se tiendra dans quelques jours il
considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce que
les français même les plus vulnérables
se rendent aux urnes
j'ai aussi demandé au premier ministre
il l'a fait encore ce matin de consulter
largement toutes les familles politiques
et elles ont exprimé la même volonté
mais il conviendra de veiller au respect
strict des gestes barrières contre le
virus et des recommandations sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous je sais aussi que
les mairies et les services de l'état
ont bien organiser les choses
des consignes renforcées seront donnés
dès demain afin que nos aînés
n'attendent pas longtemps que des fils
ne se constitue pas que les distances
soit aussi tenu et que ces fameuses
mesures barrières soient bien respectées
mais il est important dans ce moment en
suivant l'avis des scientifiques comme
nous venons de le faire d'assurer la
continuité de notre vie démocratique et
de nos institutions
voilà la priorité des priorités
aujourd'hui et donc de protéger les plus
faibles
celles et ceux que cette épidémie touche
d'abord la deuxième c'est de freiner
l'épidémie
pourquoi ministre de la santé
le directeur général de la santé voulons
expliqué à plusieurs reprises pour
éviter l'accumulation de passion qui
seront en détresse respiratoire dans nos
services d'urgence et de réanimation
il faut continuer de gagner du temps et
pour cela je vais vous demander de
continuer à faire des sacrifices et
plutôt d'en faire davantage mais pour
notre intérêt collectif dès lundi et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre les crèches les
écoles les collèges les lycées et les
universités seront fermés pour une
raison simple nos enfants et nos plus
jeunes selon les scientifiques toujours
sont celles et ceux qui propagent
semble-t-il le plus rapidement le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir de
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour
réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation pour que en effet
les personnels qui sont indispensables à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire puisse
faire garder leurs enfants et continuer
d'aller au travail pour vous protéger et
vous soigner et donc cette organisation
sera travaillée par le gouvernement dans
les prochains jours avec l'ensemble des
élus et tous les responsables sur nos
territoires
quand cela est possible je demande aux
entreprises de permettre à leurs
employés de travailler à distance les
ministres l'ont déjà annoncé nous avons
beaucoup développer le télétravail
il faut continuer cela l'intensifier au
maximum les transports publics seront
maintenues car les arrêter ce serait
tout bloquer y compris la possibilité de
soigner mais là aussi c'est à votre
responsabilité que j'en appelle et
j'invite tous les français à limiter
leurs déplacements au strict nécessaire
le gouvernement annoncera par ailleurs
des mesures pour limiter au maximum les
rassemblements dans le même temps notre
système de santé notamment dans les
services de réanimation doit se préparer
à accueillir de plus en plus de cas
graves de covile 19 et continuer à
soigner les autres malades des places
doivent se libérer dans les hôpitaux
pour cela toutes les capacités
hospitalières nationale ainsi que le
maximum de médecins et de soignants
seront mobilisés nous allons aussi
mobiliser les étudiants les jeunes
retraités des mesures exceptionnelles
seront prises en ce sens beaucoup
d'ailleurs
où commence et je veux les en remercier
j'ai vu il ya quelques jours au samu de
paris
mobilisation magnifique émouvante
exemplaires ou des étudiants à quelques
mois de leur concours était là pour
répondre aux appels et des et où des
médecins à peine retraité était revenu
pour prêter main forte c'est cela que
nous allons
collectivement généralisée en prenant
les bonnes mesures
en parallèle les soins non essentiels à
l'hôpital seront reportés c'est à dire
les opérations qui ne sont pas urgentes
tout ce qui peut nous aider à gagner du
temps la santé n'a pas de prix
le gouvernement mobilisera tous les
moyens financiers nécessaires pour
porter assistance pour prendre en charge
les malades pour sauver des vies quoi
qu'il en coûte
et beaucoup des décisions que nous
sommes en train de prendre beaucoup des
changements auxquels nous sommes en
train de procéder nous les garderons pas
ce que nous apprenons aussi de cette
crise parce que nos soignants sont
formidables d'innovation et de
mobilisation est ce que nous sommes en
train de fred en train de faire nous en
tirons toutes les leçons et sortiront
avec un système de santé encore plus
fort la mobilisation générale est
également celle de nos chercheurs de
nombreux programmes français et
européens essais cliniques sont en cours
pour produire en quantité des
diagnostics rapides performant et
efficace
nous allons améliorer les choses en la
matière et au niveau français comme
européen
les travaux sont lancés nos professeurs
avec l'appui des acteurs privés
travaillent d'ores et déjà sur plusieurs
pistes de traitements à paris marseille
lyon entre autres des protocoles ont
commencé et j'espère que dans les
prochaines semaines et prochains mois
nous aurons des premiers traitements que
nous pourrons généralisée
l'europe a tous les atouts pour offrir
au monde
l'antidote au qu'ovide 19 des équipes
sont également à pied d'oeuvre pour
inventer un vaccin
il ne pourra pas voir le jour avant
plusieurs mois mais il est porteur de
grands espoirs
la mobilisation de notre recherche
française européenne est aussi au rendez
vous et je continuerai l'intensifier
cette épreuve exige aussi une
mobilisation sociale envers les plus
démunis des plus fragiles la trêve
hivernale sera reportée de deux mois et
je demande au gouvernement des mesures
exceptionnelles dans ce contexte pour
les plus fragiles
enfin les preuves que nous traversons
exige une mobilisation générale sur le
plan économique
déjà des restaurateurs des commerçants
des artisans des hôteliers des
professionnels du tourisme de la culture
de l'événementiel du transport souffre
je le sais les entrepreneurs
s'inquiètent pour leurs carnets de
commande et tous vous vous interrogez
pour votre emploi pour votre pouvoir
d'achat je le sais c'est légitime et
avec les décisions que je viens
d'annoncer ce soir cette inquiétude
économique va évidemment s'accroître
nous n'ajouterons pas aux difficultés
sanitaires
la peur de la faillite pour les
entrepreneurs l'angoissent du chômage et
des fins de mois difficiles pour les
salariés aussi tout sera mis en oeuvre
pour protéger nos salariés et pour
protéger nos entreprises
quoi qu'il en coûte là aussi des les
jours à venir
un mécanisme exceptionnel et massif de
chômage partiel sera mise en oeuvre des
premières annonces ont été faites par
les ministres nous iront beaucoup plus
loin
l'état prendra en charge l'indemnisation
des salariés contraints à rester chez
eux
je veux en la matière que nous
inspirions de ce que les allemands ont
su par exemple mettre en oeuvre avec un
système plus généreux plus simple que le
nôtre je veux que nous puissions
préserver les emplois et les compétences
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que les
salariés puissent rester dans
l'entreprise
même s'ils sont obligés de rester à la
maison et que nous les payons je veux
que nous puissions protéger aussi nos
indépendant et donc nous prendrons
toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour donner cette garantie sur le plan
économique
toutes les entreprises qui le souhaitent
pourront reporter sans justification
sans formalité sans pénalité le paiement
des cotisations et impôts dus en mars
nous travaillerons ensuite sur les
mesures nécessaires ou d'annulation ou
de rééchelonnement
mais je ne connais que l'équipement
prend toujours trop de temps à faire
cela je veux pour nos forces économiques
des mesures simples les échéances qui
sont dus dans les prochains jours et les
prochaines semaines seront suspendus
pour toutes celles et ceux qui en ont
besoin
nous défendrons nos entreprises de
toutes tailles
nous défendrons l'ensemble des
travailleurs et des travailleuses
en parallèle j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de préparer d'ores et déjà
un plan de relance national et européen
cohérent avec nos priorités et nos
engagements pour l'avenir nous devons
aussi porter une réponse européenne
la banque centrale a déjà aujourd'hui
fait part de ses premières décisions
seront elles suffisantes je ne le crois
pas il lui appartiendra d'en prendre de
nouvelles mais je vais être là aussi
très clair avec vous ce soir nous
européens ne laisseront pas une crise
financière et économique se propage et
nous réagirons fort et nous réagirons
vite l'ensemble des gouvernements
européens doit prendre les décisions de
soutien de l'activité
puis de relance quoi qu'il en coûte la
france le fera et c'est cette ligne que
je porterai au niveau européen en votre
nom
c'est déjà ce que j'ai fait lors du
conseil exceptionnel qui s'est tenue
hier
je ne sais ce que les marchés financiers
donneront dans les prochains jours et je
serai tout aussi clair l'europe réagira
de manière
organisez massive pour protéger son
économie
je souhaite aussi que nous puissions
nous organiser sur le plan international
et j'en appelle à la responsabilité des
puissances du g7 et du g20
dès demain j'échangerais avec le
président trump pour lui proposer une
initiative exceptionnelle entre les
membres du g7
puisque c'est lui qui à la présidence ça
n'est pas la division qui permettra de
répondre à ce qui est aujourd'hui une
crise mondiale mais bien notre capacité
à voir juste et aux ensembles et à agir
ensemble
mes chers compatriotes
toutes ces mesures sont nécessaires pour
notre sécurité à tous et je vous demande
de faire bloc autour d'elle on ne vient
pas en effet à bout d'une crise d'une
telle ampleur sans faire bloc
on ne vient pas à bout d'une crise d'une
telle ampleur sans une grande discipline
individuelle et collective sans une
unité j'entends aujourd'hui dans notre
pays des voies qui vont en tous sens
certains nous disent vous n'allez pas
assez loin et voudrait tous fermés et
s'inquiète de tout de manière parfois
disproportionnées et d'autres
considèrent que ce risque n'est pas pour
eux j'ai essayé de vous donner ce soir
ce qui doit être la ligne de notre
nation toute entière
nous devons aujourd'hui éviter deux
écueils mes chers compatriotes
d'une part le repli nationaliste ce
virus il n'a pas de passeport
il nous faut unir nos forces coordonner
nos réponses coopérer la france est à
pied d'oeuvre
la coordination européenne était
essentielle et j'y veillerai nous aurons
sans doute des mesures à prendre mais il
faut les prendre pour réduire les
échanges entre les zones qui sont
touchées celles qui ne le sont pas
ce ne sont pas forcément les frontières
nationales il faut céder là à aucune
facilité aucune panique
nous aurons sans doute des mesures de
contrôle des fermetures de frontière à
prendre mais il faudra les prendre quand
elles seront pertinentes et il faudra
les prendre en européen à l'échelle
européenne
car c'est à cette échelle là que nous
avons construit nos libertés et nos
protections
l'autre écueil ce serait le repli
individualiste
jamais de telles épreuves ne se surmonte
en solitaire c'est au contraire en
solidaire en disant nous plutôt qu'en
pensant jeu que nous relèverons cet
immense défi
c'est pourquoi je veux vous dire ce soir
que je compte sur vous pour les jours
les semaines les mois à venir
je compte sur vous parce que le
gouvernement ne peut pas tout seul et
parce que nous sommes une nation
chacun a son rôle à jouer je compte sur
vous pour respecter les consignes qu'ils
sont et seront donnés par les autorités
et en particulier ses fameux gestes
barrière contre le virus
elles sont aujourd'hui encore trop peu
appliquées
cela veut dire se laver les mains
suffisamment longtemps avec du savon ou
avec des gels hydro-alcooliques
cela veut dire salut et sans embrasser
ou serrer la main pour ne pas se
transmettre le virus
cela veut dire se tenir à distance d'un
mètre ces gestes ils peuvent vous à
paraître anodin il sauve des vies des
vies c'est pourquoi mes chers
compatriotes je vous appelle
solennellement à les adopter
chacun d'entre nous détient une part de
la protection des autres à commencer par
ses proches
je compte sur vous aussi pour prendre
soin des plus vulnérables de nos
compatriotes ne pas rendre visite à nos
aînés sait et j'en ai bien conscience
un crève coeur c'est pourtant nécessaire
temporairement écrivait téléphoner
prenez des nouvelles protéger en
limitant les visites
je compte sur vous oui pour aussi aidé
le voisin qui lorsqu'il est personnel
soignant a besoin d'une solution de
garde pour ses enfants pour aller
travailler et s'occuper des autres
je compte sur les entreprises pour aider
tous les salariés qui peuvent travailler
chez eux à le faire je compte sur nous
tous pour inventer dans cette période de
nouvelles solidarités
je demande à ce titre au gouvernement de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les associations dans cette
direction cette crise doit être
l'occasion d'une mobilisation nationale
de solidarité entre générations nous en
avons les ressorts il ya déjà des
actions qui existent sur le terrain nous
pouvons faire encore plus fort tous
ensemble je compte évidemment aussi
surtout nos soignants je sais tout ce
qu'ils ont déjà fait je sais ce qu'il
leur reste à faire
le gouvernement et moi-même serons là
nous prendrons toutes nos
responsabilités pour vous je pense à
tous nos soignants à l'hôpital qui
auront les cas les plus graves à traiter
mais aussi beaucoup d'urgences je pense
aux médecins et aux infirmiers aux
infirmières à tous les soignants qui
sont aussi hors de l'hôpital qui se sont
formidablement mobilisé que nous allons
de plus en plus sollicitée dans les
semaines à venir
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous le
ministre de la santé aura l'occasion
aussi de préciser dans les prochaines
heures
les règles pour que nous vous aidions à
bien vous protéger contre le virus
le respect que nous avons envers vous et
c'est évidemment ce que la nation vous
dois les règles seront claires pour
chacun
elles seront là aussi proportionnée et
expliqué je compte sur vous toutes et
tous pour faire nation au fond pour
réveiller ce qu'il y a de meilleur en
nous pour révéler cette âme généreuse
qui par le passé a permis à la france
d'affronter les plus dures épreuves
mes chers compatriotes il nous faudra
demain tirer les leçons du moment que
nous traversons interrogé le modèle de
développement dans lequel s'est engagé
notre monde depuis des décennies et qui
dévoile ces failles au grand jour
interrogés les faiblesses de nos
démocraties ce que révèle d'ores et déjà
cette pandémie
c'est que la santé gratuite sans
conditions de revenus de parcours ou de
profession notre état providence ne sont
pas des coûts ou des charges mais des
biens précieux des atouts indispensables
quand le destin frappe ce que révèle
cette pandémie
c'est qu'il ait des biens et des
services qui doivent être placés en
dehors des lois du marché délégué notre
alimentation notre protection notre
capacité à soigner notre cadre de vie au
fond à d'autres est une folie nous
devons en reprendre le contrôle
construire plus encore que nous ne le
faisons déjà une france et une europe
souveraine une france et une europe qui
tiennent fermement leur destin en main
les prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois nécessiteront des décisions de
rupture en ce sens je les assumerai mais
le temps aujourd'hui est à la protection
de nos concitoyens et à la cohésion de
la nation
le temps est à cette union sacrée qui
consiste à suivre tous ensemble un même
chemin à ne céder à aucune panique
aucune peur à aucune facilité mais à
retrouver cette force d'âme qui est la
nôtre et qui a permis à notre peuple de
surmonter temps de crise à travers
l'histoire la france unie c'est notre
meilleur atout dans la période troublée
que nous traversons nous tiendrons tous
ensemble vive la république vive la
france
[Musique]
et voilà vous venez d'écouté donc
nouvelles locutions d' emmanuel macron
plus de 20 minutes de discours sur un
ton très solennel de la part du chef de
l'état on va tenter de décrypter tout ça
pour en parler
tout d'abord on va retrouver notre
reporter lille est pas m oz ou qui se
trouvent devant l'elysée
il a fait beaucoup de choses évidemment
très importante à retenir ce soir vous
allez tenter nous en résumé les quelques
grands points oui effectivement stéphane
une allocution très attendue du chef de
l'état qui a fait beaucoup d'annoncés
qui a reconnu que cette épidémie était
la plus grave crise sanitaire qui est
connue la france depuis un siècle
un chef de l'état emmanuel macron qui a
voulu se montrer rassurant malgré tout
qui a voulu montrer qu'il prenait les
choses en mains si l'on puis dire
il a expliqué que malgré nos efforts le
virus est en train de se propager et de
s'accélérer il a donc demandé à ce que
toutes les personnes âgées de plus de 70
ans restent autant que possible à
domicile
le chef de l'état a déclaré que
l'urgence est de protéger nos
compatriotes les plus vulnérables alors
concernant les élections municipales qui
arrive dans trois jours on s'attendait
peut-être à une annonce un report de ces
élections finalement une malienne
maquereau a annoncé que rien ne
s'opposait à ce que les français aillent
aux urnes
il a déclaré qu'il fallait assurer la
continuité de notre vie démocratique et
de nos institutions
alors parmi les autres annonces des
manuels macron le chef de l'état a
annoncé que dès lundi les crèches les
écoles les collèges les lycées et les
universités seront fermées des
fermetures qui seront valables jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
autre déclaration des madeleines macron
il a demandé à ce que les entreprises
permettent à leurs employés de
travailler au maximum à distance chez
eux il a annoncé que l'état prendra en
charge les salariés contraints de rester
chez eux
et puis des déclarations d' emmanuel
macron également concernant les
frontières puisqu'il a annoncé qu'il
faudra sans doute des mesures de
contrôle et des fermetures de frontière
à prendre si nécessaire mais à l'échelle
européenne
donc beaucoup d' annonce ce soir de la
part d' emmanuel macron il faut rappeler
que le dernier comptage en france fait
état de deux mille 281 cas dont 48 décès
morse et dernières 24 heures donc le
virus se propage vraisemblablement en
france actuellement est la grande
question ce soir était de savoir si la
france est prête à affronter cette crise
aussi les hôpitaux français sont prêts à
affronter cette crise et emmanuel macron
à semble-t-il vouloir répondre oui à
cette question
merci lit la femme on joue en direct
donc depuis l'elysée sur ce plateau pour
décrypter en cette allocution et les
mesures annoncées ce soir par emmanuel
macron nous sommes avec gilles casanova
consultant en stratégie et communication
à ses côtés pour la partie plus médical
ie8 son membre de l'académie de médecine
bonsoir re bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être là alors 20 minutes effectivement
d'annoncés importantes ça a commencé de
manière un peu douce ou en gros emmanuel
macron nous appeler à pas trop paniquer
puis c'est le monte un petit peu en
crescendo avec cette annonce qui aura
des fortes conséquences sur tout le pays
notamment la fermeture de toutes les
crèches les écoles les lycées ça ça veut
dire beaucoup gilles casanova
c'est une mesure qui va changer la lure
de nos villes essentiellement et c'est
une mesure extrêmement forte
on peut penser qu'elle a une grande
efficacité parce que c'est dans les
cours de récréation dans les
amphithéâtres ou dans les salles de
travaux dirigés dans l'est dans les
classes dans les crèches que beaucoup de
jeunes peuvent se transmettre le virus
les uns aux autres et d'une manière
silencieuse puisqu'on constate que chez
les jeunes dans de nombreux cas on ne
voit pas où on voit très peu les
symptômes et qu'on n'a probablement pas
l'appareil pour dépister des millions de
jeunes et voir qui elle coronavirus
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un débat quand
même sur ce thème parce que pas plus
tard qu'il ya quelques heures
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer exclus et clairement cette
mesure on l'a entendu on dirait que chez
nos confrères en aide en admettant
effectivement qu'il y avait un débat y
avait neuf pays de l'union européenne
qui fermer les écoles mais les autres
non je me tourne vers le médecin vous
êtes idiots y sont est-ce que vous ça
vous paraît c'est une mesure absolument
indispensable puisque les avis encore
une fois ce rapace est partagé c'est
vrai c'est indispensable
non sans doute pas mais utile oui je
pense que c'est une mesure courageuse
les enfants effectivement comme cela
vient d'être dit sont de grands
transmetteur des virus respiratoires
lorsque les affections respiratoires
séparés qu'ils circulent c'est par eux
qu'ils passent aux générations supérieur
parents grands parents les enfants sont
très mobiles puisque non seulement ils
vont en classe mais ils ont des
activités parascolaires donc ils se
déplacent beaucoup et ils ont
effectivement des contacts très
rapprochés ils n'ont pas le réflexe que
n'ont pas d'ailleurs toujours les
adultes de se laver régulièrement les
mains d'avoir des gestes d'hygiène
élémentaires donc on sait très bien on
le sait pour la grippe ans et pour
d'autres virose que les enfants sont de
grands transmetteur donc cette décision
elle est logique
elle est courageuse moi je crois que
cette prise de parole par le président
de la république marquent un tournant et
on est enfin dans une phase de
clarification est encore une semaine on
hésité à parler d'épidémie
l' oms hésité à parler de pandémie
alors que l'épidémie et la pandémie sont
là depuis plus d'un mois
mais pourquoi on n'a pas pris ces
mesures avant alors c'est pas un petit
peu tard quand même parce que on
espérait probablement que l'évolution
mondiale de cette pandémie serait plus
limitée on a le modèle du sart ce qui
effectivement au bout de quelques mois
n'a pas eu
une prolifération c'est si grave et
s'est arrêté avant l'été donc peut-être
que l'on espérait cela peut être qu'on
avait aussi peur de prendre des mesures
aussi ferme que celle qui vient d'être
annoncée aussi fermé gilles casanova
avait quand même il faut le rappeler
ça n'a échappé à personne avec des
conséquences économiques très
importantes parce que ça veut dire
beaucoup de gens à la maison qui sont en
incapacité de se rendre à leur travail
un coût important effectivement pour le
pays puisque emmanuel macron annoncé que
ça serait en gros pris en charge par par
l'état alors il faut avoir en tête que
jamais en temps de paix notre pays n'a
fait face à une crise financière majeure
et une crise sanitaire majeure en même
temps ça n'est jamais arrivé
donc on est en face d'un d'une situation
d'un modèle inédit qui demande une
réaction inédite de ce point de vue les
autorités françaises avait très mal
commencé
le premier conseil extraordinaire sur le
coronavirus s'était terminée par
l'annoncé du 49-3 sur les retraites ce
qui du point de vue de la crédibilité de
la volonté de faire barrage à ce virus
et ne pas de l'utiliser de manière
politicienne avait été quelque chose de
terrible je pense que aujourd'hui si
l'on écoute le discours d' emmanuel
macron il a compris qu'il ne fallait
plus laisser le moindre doute sur ce
sujet il sera temps plus tard de faire
le bilan de la façon dont l'exécutif et
les autorités ont géré cette crise mais
aujourd'hui on peut dire du discours d'
emmanuel macron qu'il a effectivement
entendu le propos des scientifiques
il propose des décisions qui sont en
cohérence avec ce que disent les
médecins et les scientifiques il exprime
des choses qui sont particulièrement
nouvelle c'est à dire il dit la santé
n'est pas une marchandise en
on revient que l'état discours très
nouveau dans sa bouche et il dit aussi
on ne comptera pas pour sauver les
personnes ou pour sauver les salariés ou
pour sauver les entreprises
on ne comptera pas alors vous avez bien
sûr noté la petite phrase ils font les
choses très bien en allemagne savent
indemnisés avec votre générosité
oui mais ça veut dire surtout on rompt
avec l'idéologie allemande de 3% de
déficit ou la mort on dit on ne veut pas
de la mort et donc on oublie la règle
absolue des 3%
on la met de côté tant que dure
l'épidémie est aussi d'ailleurs
la crise financière est ce qu a dit
d'ailleurs également un gala merkel un
qui a montré un peu d'inflexion sur ce
thème
autre mesure alors il y avait un petit
hall un petit suspense de ce point de
vue là toute la journée les municipales
finalement elles sont maintenues alors
toutes les écoles on les ferme et on va
voter quand même alors avec quand même
eau dans le même temps si j'ose dire le
conseil pour les personnes de plus de 70
ans les handicapés les malades
chroniques et ceux qui ont des troubles
respiratoires le conseil de rester chez
eux mêleront on doit quand même à des
voter c'est une bonne chose ça oscille
800 vous étiez étonné non je suis pas
étonné je trouve que finalement le
l'acte de vote ne demande que quelques
dizaines de minutes et peut très bien
être gérés de telle façon qu'on n'a pas
de contacts directs à moins d'un mètre
et que on va pas manipuler de budget
pouvant être contaminée en prenant un
minimum de précautions sont absolument
rien à voir avec le contact qui s'étale
sur plusieurs heures qu'ont les enfants
en milieu scolaire ou dans l'est ou dans
les lycées donc le médecin que vous êtes
trop ça plutôt cohérente
oui ce qu'on pouvait redouter c'est que
est-ce qu'on peut toujours redouté c'est
que si la courbe épidémique ne
s'infléchit pas un petit peu enfin si
elle n'est pas modéré mans propre dans
sa phase de progression
oui beaucoup moins de monde au deuxième
tour qu'au premier tour enfin ça c'est
les aléas de chute de 2,7 ce vote
gilles casanova quand on voit ce sondage
28% des français selon une étude pour 20
minutes 1 1 la semaine dernière qu'il ne
souhaitait pas aller voter par peur de
risques de transmission du coronavirus
on a un petit peu peur que ce chiffre
augmente c'est une bonne chose de les
avoir maintenus de point de vue du du
communicant de cette fois on peut penser
que annuler des élections qui se
présente si mal pour la majorité quand
on est à la tête de l'exécutif c'est
continuer sur l'erreur de base du 49 3 à
l'issue du premier conseil des ministres
extraordinaire sur le coronavirus et
donc ça c'était très difficile mais
d'autre part sur le fond on peut dire
deux choses d'abord les électeurs ne
sont pas des enfants de 8 9 ou 12 ans et
ils savent se tenir à distance les uns
les autres je pense que le discours du
président qui a été très pédagogiques a
expliqué les choses je crois qu'il a été
très regardé parce que c'était vraiment
le président qui s'exprimait est pas le
chef de la majorité pour une fois et que
donc les gens qui iront voter vont aller
voter en responsabilité
d'autre part le sondage auquel vous
faites référence
il faut le lire dans le détail et on
note que les personnes qui sont
inquiètes d'aller voter
font partie de classe d'âge qui de
manière générale ne vont pas beaucoup
voté merci gilles casanova et il lui
sourit en tout cas de nous avoir
accompagnés pour ce premier décryptage
émission spéciale aujourd'hui évidemment
consacré à cette crise du coronavirus on
reviendra bien sûr longuement sur ces
annonces très forte ces mesures très
fortes annoncées
donc il y à quelques instants par
emmanuel macron on va balayer un petit
peu tout ce qui se passe également en
europe les conséquences financières les
mesures est également annoncée hier soir
par donald trump et les conséquences en
europe conséquence sauf
financière en tout cas les annonces de
la bce cet après-midi n'auront pas à
rassurer les marchés financiers ont cédé
à la paix à la panique aujourd'hui loin
francfort madrid ont décroché la bourse
de paris qui connaît la plus forte chute
de son histoire et ce malgré les mesures
prises par la banque centrale européenne
pour soutenir les économies
la présidente de l'institution christine
lagarde parle d'un choc majeur et plaide
pour une réponse coordonnée je vous
propose d'écouter avec en avant et russe
covin darche nineteen la propagation du
coronavirus kovy 19 a été un choc majeur
pour les perspectives de croissance de
l'économie mondiale et de l'économie de
la zone euro
elle a accentué la volatilité des
marchés même si elle est finalement
temporaires par nature elle aura un
impact important sur l'activité
économique notamment ralentissant la
production en raison de la rupture des
chaînes d'approvisionnement et en
réduisant la demande intérieure et
étrangère et pour parler de ses
conséquences notamment économiques ses
conséquences également sur l'europe
je suis avec françois poulet mathis
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes
bonsoir françois poulet mathis merci
d'être avec nous alors au sujet de
l'europe un emmanuel macron qui a plaidé
pour une unité de l'europe on va parler
avec vous notamment de ses annonces sur
les frontières parce que ça aussi il ya
eu un petit peu des allers-retours au
début le gros débat sur la fermeture des
frontières s'étaient ouhlala n'ont
jamais d'avis et puis l'a finalement on
se rend compte que l'europe prend des
précautions l'allemagne qui va contrôler
davantage les français
déjà qu est ce que vous avez pensé de
cette allocution on va rester sur le
plan européen avec vous des manuels
macron aujourd'hui qui prône l'unité
justement parce qu'il est situé le
problème le problème il est européen
alors on peut très bien considérer
qu'avec une telle crise d'une telle
ampleur et bien il faut que chaque pays
qui se débrouillent referme ses
frontières règle ses problèmes pays par
pays et ce exactement tout l' inverse
alors qu'on m'entende bien il s'agit pas
d'ouvrir toutes les frontières faire en
sorte que tout le monde puisse aller
dans tous les sens c'est pas ça on peut
très bien imaginer effectivement les
mesures de restriction de passage des
frontières
par contre la dimension des solutions
que l'on peut apporter à ce problème
c'est une dimension européenne pourquoi
parce que tout simplement on le voit
bien en italie qui est actuellement en
défaut d'appareils d'assistance
respiratoire
on le voit sur la recherche des
chercheurs qui cherchent à tous les maux
par tous les moyens d'aboutir à un
vaccin plus rapidement possible mais on
le voit aussi dans la comparaison que
l'on peut faire dans les choix
politiques des différents pays
c'est peut-être instructive de savoir
comment les les opinions les les
décisions qui ont été prises d'un pays à
l'autre on take 2 effet point avait un
virus qui n'est qu'on ne connaît pas
bien dont on connaît pas bien les effets
il est très important de pouvoir
partager des expériences
donc c'est vraiment sur le plan européen
que des choses peuvent se passer mais on
dirait qu'on le découvre ce soir
françois pour les métis et magnétron qui
nous dit de probable fermeture de
frontières devront être décidés à
l'échelle européenne ça y est en france
on se réveille pourquoi on le fait
maintenant est-ce qu'il fallait pas le
faire en aimant on connaît très mal ce
virus on connaît très mal son mode de
répartition son mode de diffusion et
donc quelle est la bonne méthode
personne n'a véritablement la clé il y a
deux méthodes qui sont en concurrence
actuellement le celle de l'italie qui
consiste à tous fermés et celle de la
france qui consiste à voir un ciblage un
ciblage très précis pour faire en sorte
que les endroits où il ya des foyers
soit directement isolé maintenant
emmanuel
mâcon vient d'annoncer sur le plan de
l'éducation nationale la fermeture des
écoles et des universités
c'est un pas qui va au delà
mais chacun peut avoir des expériences
différentes comme on l'a encore est
effectivement pas d'unité sur l'europe
puisque jusqu'à présent il y avait que
neuf pays européens qui fermait les
écoles on est le dixième c'est pas c'est
pas grave c'est pas nécessaire dès le
moment où on ne connaît pas la méthode
idéale
on ne connaît pas on ne la connaît pas
et au bout d'un moment on ne la connaît
pas que des pays prennent des choix
politiques différents ce qui est
important c'est que les responsables
politiques européens se concertent
discutent entre eux et c'est de voir
comment ils avancent comment cela
progresse et puis il y aura des
décisions à prendre des décisions à
prendre
l'italie qui appellent au secours il
faut trouver des solutions à l'échelle
européenne pour ne serait ce que pour
ses histoires des six temps respiratoire
on puisse avoir des solutions
européennes qui évite des choix
absolument inadmissible que ceux tels
qu'on peut les assistés en italie donc
aujourd'hui la dimension européenne est
impérative alors l'unité de l'europe ne
pas céder au repli et nationalisme pas
non plus céder à l'individualisme les
décisions devront être prises à
l'échelle européenne
emmanuel macron effectivement là aussi
il faut être prêt s'il ya des décisions
il s'agit pas forcément que la france
accorde pour sur un même schéma
d'intervention sur les frontières voilà
voilà
bon il faut simplement qu'ils partagent
leurs expériences qui partagent leur
savoir et il faut que cela puisse
aboutir à des décisions qui sur le plan
européen sont importantes parce que
cette crise qui est absolument hors
norme va nécessiter des engagements
financiers considérables
déjà au niveau de certains des pays mais
les pays peuvent pas agir tout seul il
faut donc que l'europe
on a entendu tout à l'heure christine
lagarde il faut que l'europe autorise
certaine libéralisation par rapport à
des règles qu'elle s'était jusqu'à
maintenant octroyés et il faut
simplement savoir que ça va coûter cher
que des moments on veut éradiquer le
virus le plus rapidement possible bah il
faut agir avec des avec de l'eau salée
guiry gens semblent d'accord même la
l'inflexible normalement un gala merkel
voilà se montre beaucoup plus flexible
sur ce fameux 0% à 3% de déficit
et quel que soit le plus que 5 août ont
ils dit tout juste précise quand même
que la sphère des 3% est prévu dans les
traités il est prévu tout textuellement
dans les traités que en cas de crise
grave et nous y sommes
en cas de crise grave la règle de trois
pensant peut être interprété et c'est
bien ce qui va se passer
alors l'europe avec l'italie qui ironise
un petit peu sur l'attitude des français
jusqu'à présent enfin voilà tout au long
de la journée c'était un petit peu voilà
en gros ne fanfaronnait pas parce que ce
qui nous arrive risque fort de vous
arriver
ce scénario françois pour les métis vous
semble probable un scénario à
l'italienne ou c'était un cas
spécifiquement il s'agit donc c'est
possible et d'ailleurs je suis pas
compétent en la matière mais tous les
spécialistes tous les responsables
médicaux
que ça peut très bien arriver dans la
stratégie française il ya un élément qui
est quand même important qui est celle
d'essayer d'étaler dans le temps les cas
de cordes navires us pour éviter d'avoir
un encombrement un embouteillage des cas
graves en particulier parce que c'est ça
le problème
le problème c'est pas la plupart des
gens qui seront soumis au cours d'un
virus et qui finalement s'en tireront
pas trop balle comme une véritable
griffe
le problème c'est les cas graves c'est
ceux qui ont besoin d'assistance
respiratoire et c'est toute la
population qui est vulnérable et là il
ya partage d'expériences qui est très
important à communiquer en ce qui
concerne les personnes âgées
en ce qui concerne les malades sous
traitement des maladies chroniques
tout ça ça nécessite effectivement une
vision plus globale plus générale les
pays ne peuvent d'ailleurs il appelle à
l'aide
l'italie appelle à l'aide ce qui montre
bien que les pays seul ne peuvent plus
régler le problème
m merci françois poulet mathis
spécialiste des institutions européennes
vous restez avec nous parce que je
voulais vous faire réagir sur un autre
plan donald trump qui fait donc trembler
les marchés boursiers dès ce soir minuit
ne sera plus possible pour les européens
d'entrée sur le territoire américain
durant 30 jours une mesure draconienne
pour faire face à l'épidémie de
coronavirus dans le monde
le président américain a annoncé la nuit
dernière en pointant du doigt l'europe
et vend comment un virus étrangers seuls
ngog interdiction d'entrée à partir de
vendredi plus aucun voyageur venant
d'europe ne pourra mettre un pied aux
etats unis une décision du président
américain pour limiter la propagation du
coronavirus pour éviter que de nouveaux
cas n'entre dans notre pays nous allons
suspendre tous les voyages de l'europe
vers les états unis pendant les 30
prochains jours
les nouvelles règles entrent en vigueur
vendredi à minuit ces restrictions
seront adaptés en fonction des
conditions sur le terrain
cette mesure s'applique à toute personne
ayant séjourné dans l'espace schengen
ses 14 derniers jours
exception faite des citoyens américains
et des résidents permanents les
américains d'ailleurs invités à éviter
tout voyage à l'étranger
une annonce qui fait bondir les
dirigeants européens le coronavirus est
une crise mondiale qui n'est pas limité
un continent action l'union européenne
désapprouvent le fait que la décision
des états unis d'imposer une
interdiction de voyage était éprise de
façon unilatérale et sans consultation
30 des actions fortes pour limiter la
propagation de virus
côté français le secrétaire d'état
chargé des transports appelle à la
coopération européenne
je connais le tempérament de donald
trump qui a réagit d'ailleurs peut-être
un peu plus tard que certains autres
pays notamment les pays européens sur le
sujet il prend aujourd'hui des mesures
assez drastiques sur l'espace schengen
que nous aurons évidemment à évaluer et
je le redis ça nécessite d'autant plus
la coordination européenne autour du
président de la république une décision
américaine qui surprend aussi par ces
exceptions en effet les frontières
restent ouvertes aux britanniques
pour autant le royaume uni désapprouve
voulu aussi cette mesure
nous ne pensons pas que c'est ce qu'il
faut faire d'après les conseils que nous
recevons il n'est pas prouvé que des
interventions telles que des
interdictions de voyager est un effet
matériel cette décision prendra effet
vendredi soir mais elle a d'ores et déjà
des conséquences
l'annnonce de donald trump précipite
l'effondrement des bourses est premier
foyer donc en europe l'italie qui a
franchi la barre des douze mille cas de
contamination plus de 827 personnes sont
mortes le pays est entièrement confinée
pour le troisième jour consécutif les
mesures se renforce tous les commerces
sont désormais fermés sauf les enseignes
alimentaires et les pharmacies le récit
est signée rania baradat et prend soin
tyszkiewicz à partir de ce jeudi matin
tous les commerces du pays sont
désormais fermés sauf ceux des secteurs
de la distribution alimentaire et de la
santé
nous fermons les magasins les bars les
pubs et les restaurants et nous laissons
la possibilité de faire des livraisons à
domicile
nous fermons aussi les coiffeurs les
salons de beauté les services de cantine
qui ne peuvent pas garantir la distance
de sécurité
en ce qui concerne l'activité productive
et les activités
il faut favoriser le télétravail les
vacances la prise de congés payés des
employés de nouvelles mesures alors que
depuis mardi c'est l'ensemble de
l'italie qui est placé en confinement
tous les italiens doivent éviter les
déplacements sauf pour aller travailler
se ravitailler ou pour soins médicaux
mais difficile de respecter les
consignes à naples ils étaient plusieurs
centaines ce mercredi a défié les
interdictions de sortie
la recommandation est bien sûr de rester
chez soi mais comment est-ce possible de
rester 24 heures sur 24 à la maison
c'est impossible
je crois que si on ne fait pas des
choses en gros on ne rassemble pas de
foule
on peut au moins nous laisser sortir
pour un footing personne ne m'a
interpellé c'est le soleil et la mer qui
nous incite peut-être à sortir déjà on
commence à être nostalgique de la vie
d'avant
sincèrement j'ai juste voulu faire une
petite promenade rien d'autre sans
exagérer bien sûr on est inquiet mais il
ya beaucoup d'espoir que tous résolvent
nous savons que tout ça dépend aussi de
nous et surtout de notre façon de nous
comporter
un peu plus au nord à rome
les tories se sont fait rares dans les
rues du centre de la capitale
une situation qui ne devrait pas
s'arranger dans les prochains jours une
flopée de compagnies aériennes ont
annoncé suspendre leurs liaisons avec
l'italie
parmi elles air france ryanair et
easyjet et british airways au sol les
restrictions sont aussi de rigueur
l'autriche a procédé ce mercredi à la
quasi fermeture de sa frontière
les automobilistes en provenance
d'italie doivent désormais présenter un
certificat médical
même chose à la frontière avec la
slovénie
il faut dire que l'épidémie se propage
de façon alarmante en italie deuxième
foyer de l'épidémie dans le monde pour
faire face à l'urgence sanitaire du cp
compter annoncé une enveloppe de
plusieurs milliards d'euros et à bien à
peine un délai bella tôt nous venons
d'approuver la location d'une somme
extraordinaire de 25 milliards d'euros
et nous sommes conscients des
difficultés auxquelles le pays est
confronté dans cette situation d'urgence
à noter également que tous les
événements sportifs nationaux dont le
championnat de football sont suspendus
des mesures drastiques qui doivent
rester en vigueur au moins jusqu'au 3
avril
le premier ministre italien promet les
premiers effets de ce grand effort
d'ici une quinzaine de jours et pour en
parler nous sommes avec olivier goujon
journaliste écrivain et scénariste qui
se trouve actuellement à milan on plaint
confinement bonsoir olivier goujon merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
tout d'abord première question comment
tu es comment allez vous comment vous
vivez ce confinement à milan bonsoir
merci merci ca va écouter ça va bien
comme comment le vit on sort pas on peut
pas en fait c'est une précision sur ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure on peut
sortir
il s'agit de sortir avec une ce qu'on
appelle une auto certification c'est à
dire que on certifie en promet quand
sort pour un bon motif
donc on peut sortir pour faire des
courses mais
l'essentiel parce que de toute façon les
magasins sont fermés on peut sortir pour
raisons de santé c'est à dire se rendre
à des consultations par exemple ou pour
des raisons urgentes
on peut également s'y pour une bonne
raison encore une fois voyager voilà
donc on peut sortir qu'il existe des
avants dont a mis en place un système
d'avant pour des gens qui qui
transgresse les nouvelles normes pour de
mauvaises raisons
on a beaucoup diminué la possibilité des
mauvaises raisons puisque de toute façon
tous les bars les discothèques les
restaurants tout est fermé les magasins
un peu plus en plus car de shopping donc
ya pas vraiment non plus de raison de
sortir en sorte pour l'essentiel pour
les choses un compte pas hésité on ne
peut plus faire du shopping
est-ce qu'on peut tout de même aller
dans les pharmacies et dans les
supermarchés j'imagine comment ça se
passait ce que on n'en est pas au
rationnement chine ont fait la queue
pour faire les courses par exemple alors
les pharmacies s'est ouvert certaines
pharmacies ont mis en place un système
de guichet avec des files d'attentes
les supermarchés sont ouverts également
de manière un petit peu fractionné ont
fait la queue dehors en respectant un
distance d'un mètre ou d'un mètre
cinquante
et puis à l'intérieur d'un voilà on fait
rentrer les gens 5 par 5 10 par 10 20
par vinça dépend de la taille d'un des
magasins voilà il n'y a pas de
rationnement les magasins sont
approvisionnés
ça marche pas très bien en revanche le
système de livraison à domicile puisque
évidemment il ya énormément d'attentes
tout le monde le demande et donc ça
fonctionne pas mais on retrouve de tout
dans les magasins comment réagit la
population est ce qu'elle est inquiète
est ce que finalement il ya beaucoup de
résilience beaucoup de calme de la part
des italiens alors j'entendais tout à
l'heure
le président m'a cran je trouve que en
italie justement en fait nation c'est à
dire que il ya eu par exemple dimanche
dernier quand il ya eu les premières
rumeurs de confinement à milan il ya eu
des mouvements de panique les trains ont
été pris d'assaut les gens essayaient de
s'échapper vers le sud sur tout ce qui
avait de la famille dans le sud de
l'italie qui est beaucoup moins touchés
vous le savez est donc on a eu quelques
mouvements panique
également début mars quand on a quand on
a vu les premiers confinement arrivé à
acodo n'ya pas billard là on a eu des
des scènes un petit peu dramatique
également dans les supermarchés qui
étaient pris d'assaut
mais globalement globalement l'italie
réagit très bien les gens sont
solidaires ils sont responsables et ils
assument globalement un comportement
très digne on entend parfois des choses
peut-être inquiétante notamment sur
l'état des hôpitaux en italie alors aux
rumeurs infos ou intox notamment
voilà pas de place dans les morts on est
obligés d'évacuer les corps pour les
enterrer ailleurs est ce que tout ça
c'est de l'intox on sait la véritable
situation en italie dans cdac la
véritable situation c'est à dire que
globalement si vous voulez le la france
et l'italie choisisse de réagir de
manière diamétralement opposées à la
crise pour à peu près les mêmes raisons
qui les raisons en gros c'est des
raisons politiques économiques et
sociales il s'agit notamment de deux de
masquer des politiques de santé qui ont
été conçus suivi la même voie depuis 30
ans et puis qu'on menait les pays la
france l'italie où il
ils en sont aujourd'hui c'est à dire
avec un hôpital public ardemment sa cage
et on peut le dire comme ça alors en
italie oui aujourd'hui il ya des
carences dans les hôpitaux le personnel
est très très mobilisé
on fait travailler on fait revenir des
médecins ont fait travailler des
étudiants voilà tout le monde est sur le
pont pour le dire de manière un peu
triviale malgré tout évidemment on voit
bien qu'avec 5 ou 6000 personnes
hospitalisées d'un coup le le système de
santé atteint ses limites
on a vu en a vu des cas dramatiques on a
vu des affirme hier dire qu'elle devait
faire des choix pour des listes
d'attentes à 1
enfin le devait mettre en place des
listes d'attentes pour l'accès à des
appareils respiratoires par exemple
c'est dramatique on est quand même en
train de parler de d'un des pays les
plus riches du monde quoi les italiens
notamment les médecins italiens
confiante qui peut ironiser sur la
critique française qui semblait
minimiser les dangers du coc vie de 19
pour vous vous avez écouté visiblement
emmanuel mettront ce soir est ce que il
a pris la mesure en fin de ce danger du
coroner virus je n'en suis pas convaincu
du tout je pense que écoutez c'est c'est
assez simple finalement les médecins
nous disent que les courbes de
progression du virus sont parallèles et
se suivent à entre la france et l'italie
et que la france
simplement quelques jours de retard sur
l'italie donc la france choisit de
réagir en faisant profil bas donc par
exemple on le voit très bien au niveau
des tests tampon qui sont effectués sur
la population en italie on a déjà
effectué près de 80 mille tests en
france on refuse de dire combien de test
on a effectué en sait cependant que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
donc en fait en ne testant pas la
population si vous voulez naturellement
on va trouver moins de 2 on va trouver
moins de cas positifs
c'est la même chose sur les doubles
pathologie en italie on comptabilise
dans la catégorie décès du corps navires
us énormément de double double
pathologie je rappelle que en lombardie
par exemple la moyenne d'âge des décès
et de 80 non mais c'est peut-être des
gens qu aurait eu encore deux trois
quatre cinq ans de vie sans le corps un
avis russe ils sont comptabilisés dans
les décès dûs coronavirus en france
s'ils sont pas détectés ils sont
naturellement pas comptabilisés dans les
décès du co en alliage
donc j'ai l'impression c'est pas une
impression de leurs certitudes quand on
fait profil bas sur la réaction
française
l'italie de son côté a peut-être
effectivement dramatiser la réaction
depuis le début mais finalement on
s'aperçoit d'ailleurs on a des premiers
résultats on s'aperçoit que la côte
d'agneau à pabbi ya les confinements
portent leurs fruits
l'épidémie ne progresse plus à codognan
a pas bien on sait que les confinements
en fonctionner en chine
et puis énormément de médecins français
nous disent aussi que à partir d'un
certain niveau de contamination c'est la
seule réponse mercerie réponse efficace
merci beaucoup olivier goujon
journaliste scénariste écrivain confiné
actuellement à milan merci de ce point
complet de la situation vivait
actuellement en italie les 21h passé de
minutes soyez les bienvenus si vous nous
rejoignez voici les titres avec un seul
thème ce soir la crise du coronavirus et
emmanuel macron qui s'est adressé aux
français il y à une heure une allocution
de plus de vingt minutes durant laquelle
le président de la république a annoncé
plusieurs mesures fortes
la fermeture des écoles et des
universités dès lundi la limitation des
déplacements pour l'ensemble des
français en particulier pour les
personnes âgées plus de plus de 70 ans
et celles qui souffrent de maladies
chroniques qui sont donc invités à
rester chez elle
les municipales elle en revanche auront
bien lieu précise le président de la
république
l'épidémie qui s'étend dans toute
l'europe l'italie a dépassé le cap des
1000 morts le royaume-uni évoquent entre
cinq et dix mille personnes infectées
l'allemagne elle renforce ses contrôles
à la frontière avec la france aux états
unis donald trump ferme ses portes aux
étrangers venant d'europe pour 30 jours
les marchés ont cédé une nouvelle fois à
la panique aujourd'hui les annonces de
la bce n'ont pas rassuré conséquence des
débâcles has historique à paris londres
francfort wall street sombre et se
reprend légèrement le cac 40 lui a
clôturé à - 12,28 %
et alors que le pays les pays du monde
entier sont confrontés à cette crise du
coronavirus y aura-t-il un avant et un
après quels enseignements les pays
peuvent-ils tirer de ce bouleversement
quelle décision prendre pour l'avenir ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
[Musique]
emmanuel macron s'est donc exprimé
pendant plus de 20 minutes tout à
l'heure à 20 heures avec des mesures
fortes on va retrouver tout de suite
notre reporter ni la fin vous vous
devant le palais de l'elysée où le
président français s'est donc exprimé
lit la femme vous avez suivi cette
allocution que faut-il retenir du
discours d' emmanuel macron oui c'est
fanny pendant cette allocution qui était
très attendu emmanuel macron a voulu se
montrer rassurant même si il a pris
l'ampleur de la crise à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés
le chef de l'état a expliqué qu'il avait
consulté les plus grands experts avant
de prendre les décisions qu'il a annoncé
ce soir parmi ces décisions
il a demandé à ce que toutes les
personnes de plus de 70 ans restent
autant que possible chez elles
il a aussi annoncé la fermeture des
établissements scolaires et
universitaires dès lundi propose de
l'écouter dès lundi et jusqu'à nouvel
ordre les crèches les écoles les
collèges les lycées et les universités
seront fermés pour une raison simple nos
enfants et nos plus jeunes selon les
scientifiques toujours sont celles et
ceux qui propagent semble-t-il le plus
rapidement le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir de
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation pour que en effet
les personnels qui sont indispensables à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire puisse
faire garder leurs enfants et continuer
d'aller au travail pour vous protéger
vous soigner et donc cette organisation
sera travaillée par le gouvernement dans
les prochains jours avec l'ensemble des
élus et tous les responsables sur nos
territoires et prend la question était
de savoir si les élections municipales
seraient reportées elles auront bien
le bien lieu c'est la décision du chef
de l'état qui a expliqué que rien ne
s'oppose à ce que les français aillent
aux urnes
il a consulté les différents partis
gérard larcher aussi le président du
sénat est donc les élections municipales
auront lieu écouter emmanuel macron j'ai
interrogé les scientifiques sur nos
élections municipales dont le premier
tour se tiendra dans quelques jours il
considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce que
les français même les plus vulnérables
se rendre aux urnes
j'ai aussi demandé au premier ministre
il l'a fait encore ce matin de consulter
largement toutes les familles politiques
et elles ont exprimé la même volonté
mais il conviendra de veiller au respect
strict des gestes barrières contre le
virus et des recommandations sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous alors la question
avant cette allocution du chef de l'état
était de savoir si la france était prête
à affronter cette crise si les hôpitaux
français était prêt à affronter cette
crise et semble ce soir qu emmanuel
macron ait voulu répondre oui à ces
questions
merci lit la femme ouzou pour ce point
complet et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean-louis quoique microbiologiste
professeur agréé chez agrégé au
val-de-grâce fondateur de mes vaccins
point net
bonsoir jean loïc waka merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france vous avez
je n'imagine suivi cette allocution d'
emmanuel macron globalement on ira dans
le détail après ce que vous êtes
satisfait en tout cas de cette tonalité
de son torrent et de ces mesures fortes
du président de la république
aujourd'hui
oui je pense que les autorités
sanitaires ont pris la mesure du
problème et le président l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises il a suivi les
conseils des scientifiques et il a
consultées de manière assez large et les
scientifiques qui ont d'une autorité sur
la question et je pense que j'ai fait
les bonnes décisions ont été prises des
décisions assez forte comme par exemple
la ferme du ru de la fermeture de toutes
les écoles collèges lycées universités
c'est un essai décision importante qui
je crois qu'il fallait la prendre
effectivement c'était a fait partager
j'entendais encore le ministre blanquet
redire il ya quelques jours qu'il n'y
aurait pas de fermetures d'écoles en
france en tout cas pour le moment à
votre avis qu'est ce qui a fait changer
d'avis emmanuel macron sur ce plan je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas qui je sais pas
s'il a changé d'avis qui ce qu'il a dit
lui en tout cas c'est que les experts
ont fait des recommandations et qui
s'est appuyé sur ses recommandations
et effectivement quand on regarde quand
on écoute les experts actuellement les
épidémiologistes qui s'intéresse de près
à cette question et bien on sait qu'il
ya un point crucial et c'est le
confinement la distance sociale et que
pour éviter la propagation de la maladie
il faut en effet éviter tous les cinq
ans
il fut géré on sait que les ensembles
les jeunes adultes peuvent être
infectées de manière symptomatique donc
ils ne savent pas
peuvent transmettre le virus et donc
c'est un facteur de diffusion important
je pense qu'un effet c'est de ce point
de vue là il ne très sage décision même
si elle est assez lourde de conséquences
mais je pense qu'il fallait la prendre
avant qu'on soit totalement débordés
parce qu'on voit que l'épidémie
progresse vite et on sait que les cas
qu'on compte aujourd'hui sont la partie
émergée de l'iceberg et biologique des
désaffections a comme en avion russe
autre recommandation de la part du
président de la république le travail à
distance l'intensification du
télétravail la limitation des
déplacements au strict nécessaire ça
aussi ça vous paraît c'est important oui
sans relève exactement toujours du même
principe
si c'est le mot clé un augmenter la
distance sociale
le confinement chaque fois que c'est
possible si un enfant est malade il faut
absolument le garder à la maison
donc voilà une faire tout ce qui est
tout ce qu on peut tout ce qu'ils
inventent entre pouvoirs shakoor à titre
individuel et les collectivités
également pour faire en sorte qu'al la
diffusion du virus soit ralentie et que
les hôpitaux ne sont pas débordés par
les urgences et les cas graves
aujourd'hui le plus important gens lui
quoique c'est clairement de comme l'a
dit le président de la république de
gagner du temps et de protéger les plus
vénérables parce que les plus jeunes
viendront ensuite est ce qu ils avaient
l'air de dire notamment à l'hôpital
oui c'est exactement ça parce que le
risque auquel on risque ça vous pourrez
être confrontés c'est d'être débordés ne
pas avoir assez d'oxygène de
respirateurs pour sauver des vies et
pour ça il faut aplanir la courbe le pic
d'infection et si on arrive à faire en
sorte que soient mieux réparties dans le
temps pour mieux les prendre en charge
alors la prise en charge
on a eu beaucoup de témoignages
peut-être vous aussi autour de vous tout
simplement des proches de personnes qui
se sentaient malades qui toussait qui
ont appelé
le 15 le samu comme on nous le conseille
sauf que l'on entend souvent longtemps
trois heures pour un exemple proche de
nous
on a ensuite conseillé à cette personne
de se diriger vers la médecine libérale
qui elle est également dépassé débordés
que doit-on faire aujourd'hui quand on a
des symptômes de coronavirus en tout cas
des symptômes qu'on a de la fièvre ou
comptons ce qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
je pense qu'il faut un effet appeler le
et on doit être guidé alors je ne peux
pas me prononcer sur les cas
particuliers que vous mentionnez mais ce
que je peux dire c'est que le 15 est
habilité à donner les bons conseils
alors si tu n'as section sensible de
gravité sans essoufflement parce que le
signe clé c'est ça c'est d'essoufflement
eh bien oui à ce n'est pas très grave si
la personne doit attendre deux trois
heures
mais en effet il faut éviter ce souvent
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
chez les enfants les jeunes adultes le
lait la maladie est souvent très modérée
est le principal risque associés s'est
cassé la diffusion ou plus que les cas
eux-mêmes
même s'il faut toujours être très
vigilant qui peut y avoir aussi des cas
graves chez les adultes alors en
allemagne les experts en repris
d'ailleurs par angela merkel prévoyez
que 60 à 70 personnes seraient
contaminées est ce que
selon vous c'est pareil en france est ce
qu'on peut donner ce type de chiffres
sans se tromper
vous avez dit combien entre 60 et 70
personnes seraient contaminées il
parlait en l'occurrence des allemands
c'était des médecins allemands ça veut
dire 70%
oui exactement pense oui oui oui non
vous êtes il 70 personnes non car sans
pardon
ah non non mais c'est pas grave oui eh
bien écoutez je je pense qu'il faut être
toujours très prudent quand on donne des
chiffres sur une épidémie parce qu'il ya
de nombreux facteurs qui peuvent moduler
l'évolution d'une épidémique et je crois
que le ce qu'il faut faire c'est le
maximum à aa laisse tenter
aujourd'hui après faire des spéculations
sur l'avenir c'est toujours très
hasardeux et moi je ne me restera pas
merci en tout cas jean louis quoi
d'avoir été avec nous microbiologiste
professeur agrégé au 22 grâce et
fondateur de mes vaccins point est merci
d'avoir été avec nous et conséquences
économiques les annonces de la bce cet
après-midi n'auront pas rassuré les
marchés financiers ont cédé à la panique
à londres francfort madrid ont décroché
en début d'après midi la bourse de paris
connaît la plus forte chute de son
histoire et ce malgré les mesures prises
par la banque centrale européenne pour
soutenir les économies
la présidente de l'institution christine
lagarde parle là d'un choc majeur et
plaide pour une réponse coordonnée et
écouter ce prix avec en avant et russe
covington nineteen la propagation du
coroner virus kovy 19 a été un choc
majeur pour les perspectives de
croissance de l'économie mondiale et de
l'économie de la zone euro
l accentuer la volatilité des marchés
même si elle est finalement temporaires
par nature elle aura un impact important
sur l'activité économique notamment
ralentissant la production en raison de
la rupture des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et en réduisant la
demande intérieure et étrangère
oui je suis de des cotations boursières
ce sondage ne sont d'ailleurs pas la
seule conséquence de la pandémie
coronavirus la production économique des
pays touchés par la crise et menacé le
risque d'un normalement
de la crise financière et réelle les
explications de guillaume à rossi il ne
fait décidément pas bon être trader ces
jours ci les market makers hurle dans le
pit tout le monde tente de fermer ses
positions et dans les fonds les niveaux
de value at risk sont déclenchés en
clair les bourses du monde entier sont
en pleine panique et l'europe ne fait
pas exception
ce jeudi le cac 40 avait perdu 29%
depuis le 19 février dernier
idem pour le dax c'est l'équivalent
allemand du cac 40 qui a perdu plus de
24%
même chose en italie bien sûr parce que
30% depuis trois semaines et plus de 21%
pour le footsie britannique
et si les responsables politiques et des
principales institutions européennes
s'inquiètent c'est que les courbes que
vous venez de voir en rappelle d'autres
un peu plus anciennes voici à nouveau la
cotation du cac 40 vous voyez là aussi
une chute sévère de l' indice
sauf qu'il s'agit cette fois des cours
de 2008 en pleine crise financière un
épisode dont les économies du globe ne
se sont toujours pas complètement remise
et malheureusement les annonces de la
bce ont clairement échoué à rassurer les
marchés les bourses de paris londres ou
encore milan ont plongé encore un peu
plus après que francfort a déclaré
vouloir maintenir ses taux directeurs la
bce qui a pourtant également annoncé un
programme de prêts pour les pme les plus
touchés par le corona virus ainsi qu'à
rachat de 120 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires de dette publique et
privée pour cette année et les états ne
sont d'ailleurs pas en reste
l'italie compte débloquer 25 milliards
d'euros pour lutter contre le coc vide
le royaume uni a lui aussi annoncé son
plan de 34 milliards et d'autres pays
d'europe ont pris des mesures censés
soulager leurs économies chaque état y
va de son initiative particulière et
c'est bien le problème
les états du vieux continent donc pas
encore pris de réelles actions
financières d'envergure coordonner ce
qui a d'ailleurs provoqué la colère de
la patronne de la bce
christine lagarde qui a dénoncé je cite
la complaisance et la lenteur des
dirigeants en particulier en zone euro
et pourtant le danger est réel
au delà de la crise sanitaire l'économie
mondiale semble bien être un tournant
car avec les quarantaine et les
fermetures de frontières l'économie
tourne de plus en plus au ralenti des
pme sont les plus touchés notamment
celles liées au tourisme
or ces pme au peu de trésorerie et
risque bien de se retrouver en cessation
de paiement avec des prêts non
remboursés ce qui affole à juste titre
les marchés des marchés en berne cela
signifie également moins de capacité de
financement pour les plus grosses
entreprises qui voient également leur
capitalisation fondre au rythme de la
chute boursière des banques qui à la fin
ne se prêtent plus entre elles et se
retrouve à court de liquidités bref tout
ceci est connu les crises économiques et
financières s'auto alimente
et alors que lieu survit grâce à la
politique généreuse de la bce depuis la
dernière crise
le coronavirus légué par la chauve
souris pourrait bien être le cygne noir
de cette décennie qui commence à peine
un signe dont le chant accompagne une
nouvelle récession économique et autres
conséquences en europe les contrôles
sont renforcés à la frontière entre la
france et l'allemagne depuis cet après
midi une mesure décidée par le
gouvernement fédéral allemand pour
endiguer l'épidémie c'est notamment le
cas en moselle et dans les deux barques
départements alsaciens les policiers
allemands équipés de masques et de
grands protection demande
systématiquement aux automobilistes et
aux piétons s'ils toussent
ils se sentent souffrent ou ce qu'ils
ont la fièvre ils prennent parfois leur
température hier l'allemagne avait placé
le grand test comme une région à risques
berlin qui demande aussi aux
travailleurs français de ne pas venir en
allemagne et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis berlin avec ulrich
bruckner analyste politique c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir rica bruckner merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france contrôles à
la frontière avec la france ça y est on
change d'avis on va enfin contrôler les
frontières
désormais cela a toujours été une option
si nécessaire nous l'avons bien vu lors
d'événements sportifs nationaux afin
d'éviter l'afflux de hooligans et il
s'agit ici d'arrêter le flux libre du
virus donc cela fait sens et cela ne
remet pas en question fondamentalement
l'idée de l'ouverture des frontières
dans la zone schengen vont consister ces
contrôles de frontières parce qu'on sait
que de nombreux notamment aux
strasbourgeois francis franchissent
chaque jour cette frontière qui vous
sépare de la france comment ça va se
passer comment on va gérer ces personnes
je pense qu'il s'agit d'une action
symbolique afin de montrer aux personnes
qui souhaitent pénétrer en allemagne
ainsi qu'aux citoyens allemands que
l'état est conscient des conséquences de
la libre circulation du virus
idéalement il faudrait réduire les
contacts sociaux autant que possible le
contrôle aux frontières et le contrôle
de la température en cas de doute
n'empêche pas à la circulation du virus
mais crée une sensation une prise de
conscience qui vraiment nécessaire que
je me rende ou devrais-je plutôt rester
à la maison ou au sein des communautés
alors la france doit prendre la mesure
du danger disait encore cet après midi
des correspondants italiens en allemagne
est-ce que de votre côté vous estimez
que votre pays a pris la mesure du
danger
sur l'allemagne a pris la mesure du
danger le développement de services
pandémie dépens en fonction des pays
comme lorsqu'on étudie l'explosion
quasiment dans certains pays comme en
corée ou en italie a été plus rapide que
dans d'autres pays l'allemagne
comment est bien consciente que cela
pourrait également arriver ici le fait
que les chiffres soient plus basse que
dans d'autres pays ne signifie pas que
cela ne peut pas arriver ni faudrait
autant que possible retardé mais il est
impossible de l'empêcher on dit souvent
qu'un gala merkel elle n'est pas très
friand et un de ses conférences de
presse quotidiennes on a vu beaucoup un
nom en france emmanuel macron tous les
jours en visite sur les chaînes info
tantôt dans un ehpad tantôt dans un
hôpital un gala merkel elle quel est son
mode de communication l'a vu s'exprimer
récemment mais est-ce qu'elle est plutôt
discrète les allemands sont satisfaits
en tout cas de ce traitement de la crise
par la chancelière au phosphore jaune
faut 4 tout d'abord il ne faut pas
oublier que nous avons des systèmes
politiques très différents le système
présidentiel en france un président très
expansif
c'est différent en matière de
personnalités comme en matière de rôle
politique que la merkel s'est depuis
2015 qu'elle peut bien gérer une crise
est là à traiter les problèmes tels que
la crise lehman fukushima l'occupation
de la crimée la crise en grec
la crise en grèce et elle gère également
la crise actuelle avec l'afflux des
migrants en nombre aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'une catastrophe naturelle
et elle essaie de dire que ce en ce
moment il n'est pas nécessaire de faire
des actions politiques symboliques
elle fait confiance à la solidité du
système fédéral allemand avec ses
différentes couches et elle pense que le
ministre travaille bien qu'il faut
coopérer
on s'est engueulés merkel très attachée
aux dogmes européen en tout cas du
déficit de 2 3 % on l'a entendu dire que
quelques soirées le coup en tout cas la
santé des allemands seraient
prioritaires ça vous a étonné vous en
tant que observateurs cela ne lui
rendent pas car elle a toujours voulu
trouver des solutions au niveau européen
le pire serait d'essayer de trouver des
responsables de montrer des pays de
dénoncer des pays qui seraient plus ou
moins responsable
nous devons tous faire notre possible et
l'idéal serait de bien nous coopérer
c'est extrêmement important dans les
régions frontalières notamment et je
pense également que nous trouvons une
solution européenne
merci beaucoup ulrich brut mère alice
politique d'avoir été en direct avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
merci à vous restez avec nous dans
quelques instants sur ce sera notre face
à face sur la crise du cône rona virus
encore une fois un bouleversement pour
le monde entier et quelles leçons en
tirer nos
invité en débattrons
[Musique]
je
si on chantait mais review bah tu dis
quoi
une chanson d orgue et récits aussi
moyer connais bien les yoyos libye
envoyez vos paniers honte
le zune autres piquionne dalo guirassy
et biskra ya des couleurs d'alinghi coda
un total de 40 ans
à s'en tenir là là je chante beaucoup
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le lac 6 anti fait partie d'une réserve
naturelle à haute altitude
c'est là que le célèbre fleuve le site
arômes commence son voyage
c'est la principale voie navigable
d'indonésie
le site a room est désormais une fosse
septique géante
le fleuve s'étend sur 300 kilomètres de
sa source à son embouchure et compte
plus de 2000 installations industrielles
réparties le long de ses rives
l'eau est devenue noire parce que les
déchets liquides de lusine ne sont pas
filtrées
lors du site arômes iric plus de 4000
rizières et fournit de l'eau potable à
25 millions de personnes
or nous n'avons qu'un fleuve et c'est le
fleuve le plus polluées du monde
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques dans notre pays
et sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
quelle que soit la qualité expertise
indéniable nos soldats ils ne peuvent
gagner la guerre pour la raison que je
vais maintenant et peuvent faire un peu
plus de 5000 militaires français à
l'efficacité certes reconnu sur une zone
aussi vaste même renforcé par cinq mille
soldats promis par les pays vieux zinc
da selaou les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
apollo
il verra t-on équipements et le cas sera
ma morceaux choisis
[Musique]
ayrault a souhaité il prendra ton âme
et puis de festivals qui est dit
[Musique]
avant il y avait trois chaman maintenant
ils sont beaucoup les pèlerins ceux qui
sont venus pour un service de prières
par là
oh
[Musique]
non
21h30 heure française émission ce soir
consacrée si vous nous rejoignez à la
crise du coronavirus emmanuel macron qui
s'est adressé aux français il y a
maintenant une heure et demie une
allocution de plus de 20 minutes avec
des mesures fortes on y reviendra dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons
également sur les conséquences de cette
crise dans mon dur at il un avant lui
aura-t-il un après quelles leçons en
tirer c'est l'objet de notre face à face
ce soir et pour décrypter tout ceci est
en parler nous sommes avec patrick
mennucci conseiller municipal de
marseille bonsoir on sort que mennucci
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
didier maïsto président de sud radio
bonsoir didier merci d'être là l'on va
voilà c'était face à face un petit peu
particulier aujourd'hui on va le diviser
en deux on va évidemment décrypter ces
mesures fortes en d'emmanuel macro
aujourd'hui et puis on ira un petit peu
voir plus loin quelle leçon tirer de
cette crise du corona virus je vous
propose tout d'abord d'écouter une
partie de cette allocution sur la
fermeture des écoles des crèches et des
collèges annoncé par le président de la
république tout à l'heure dès lundi et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre les crèches les
écoles les collèges les lycées et des
universités seront fermés pour une
raison simple nos enfants et nos plus
jeunes selon les scientifiques toujours
sont celles et ceux qui propagent
semble-t-il le plus rapidement le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir de
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation
pour que en effet les personnels qui
sont indispensables à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire puisse faire garder
leurs enfants et continuer d'aller au
travail pour vous protéger et vous
soigner et donc cette organisation sera
travaillée par le gouvernement dans les
prochains jours avec l'ensemble des élus
et tous les responsables sur nos
territoires
on va là messieurs je voulais vous faire
écouter ce sont parce que c'est
certainement l'une des mesures qui aura
le plus de conséquences sur les français
patrick mennucci vous êtes satisfait par
cette annonce je crois pas qu on puisse
être satisfait ses besoins ce qu'on peut
dire vous attendiez non je m'attendais
pas à la fermeture des écoles je dois le
dire mais c'est très manifestement
ministre blanquart non je ne m'y
attendais pas parce que ce matin au
ministre et planétaire a dit qu'il ne
fermerait pas les écoles de comment
qu'il ya eu sans doute aujourd'hui à la
fois sur cette question mais aussi sur
la question des élections municipales il
ya eu des hésitations en tout cas des
discussions maintenant il est difficile
quand on est un commentateur et de de
contester les mesures du président appui
dans la mesure où on considère je
suppose que c'est la vérité qu'il a
c'est ce qu'il a dit en tout cas des
informations des courbes qui peuvent
montrer que dans les quinze jours qui
viennent il nous allons avoir le pic
épidémique
donc si effectivement les écoles
participent de cela
la logique est effectivement de les
fermer mais ce combat c'est pourquoi la
matinée on disait qu aurait fermé pas
simplement la halle est là les
conséquences pour les français sont
considérables et chacun d'entre nous
peut regarder dans sa famille
j'ai eu ma fille tout à l'heure qu'il
est les humains qui est évidemment
stupéfaite parce que l'attelage faire
voilà on va être obligé de s'adapter à
tout ça je crois qu'il faut dans des
circonstances comme celles là moi j'ai
suffisamment critiqué un président un
public sur beaucoup de choses
bon voilà après je suis pas dupe non
plus de la posture de là peut-être de la
possibilité que voit le président de la
république dans cette crise de montrer
aux français qu il est le commandant en
chef en quelque sorte
abbas et c'était l'occasion en or didier
maïsto il a dit d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron faire nation voilà la posture du
chef de l'état paternaliste vous l'avez
trouvé comment avant justement d'aller
dans le détail de ces mesures que vous
approuvez ou pas je ne sais pas moi je
me trouvais fidèle à lui-même dans le en
même temps on a découvert ce soir qu'il
allait réinventer un modèle on l'a
presque vue communiste
puisqu'il semble en remettre en cause un
peu le néo l'aider à le néolibéralisme
même si la silla pas dit on allait
réfléchir à un nouveau modèle il parle
de nation ce qui est quand même étrange
dans sa bouche et en même temps il parle
d'europe
finalement à la fin on se dit mais nous
parle tout de quoi la du fric site
puisque il va remettre en cause les
équilibres européen et c'est alors un
moment il parle pour l'europe un moment
pour la france
bon finalement c'est un exercice certes
compliqué mais c'est aussi la stratégie
qui a été choisi de faire du en même
temps c'est à dire on ferme sans fermer
on ferme les lieux clos mais on continue
à aller dans les transports en commun on
continue de s'appeler a limité les poils
à mai mais ça tout le monde
si vous voulez voilà on voit jamais au
bout d'une véritable démarche et moi ce
soir j'ai pas compris l'armée les écoles
quand même enfin c'est bien le moins
qu'on puisse faire est quand même toute
la journée toute la journée et enfin ne
font pas cette journée était athée comme
un peu folle parce qu'on est parti et la
réunion des présidents de parti ce matin
ça pas du tout été évoquée puis au fil
de la journée puisque on connaît un
petit peu l'histoire maintenant est
sortie l'idée de reporter les
municipales ce que tout le monde
finalement aurait un petit peu compris
parce que c'est un facteur de 2 des
changes du virus
il ya des queues ya les dépouilles
membres 7,7 cette mesure surtout que la
sincérité du scrutin va en être affecté
dans la mesure où les plus anciens
restes à la maison tout le monde
l'aurait compris donc après l'idée
c'était l'article 16 pas l'article 16-1
décret pour repousser mais on repoussait
pas assez loin et le président du sénat
françois baroin à l'hidalgo ou martine
aubry puisqu'on a su un peu de
l'intérieur s'y sont fermement opposés
en en disant vous allez pas maintenant à
six a si peu de jours du premier tour
changer les règles il fallait le faire
avant
ça c'est le premier point mais le
deuxième point par rapport à ce comité
scientifique qu'il découvre un peu comme
on découvre l'eau tiède
ça ça fait quand même plusieurs semaines
que les meilleurs scientifiques et pas
seulement les français comme il l'a dit
alerte sur la courbe exponentielle
du virus puis là on découvre ce matin on
découvre ce soir l'eau chaude que ce que
tout le monde savait déjà dans l'eau
comme dans la communauté scientifique
ce que les scientifiques s'échiner à
dire sur tous les modes avec la retenue
qui est la leur parce qu'ils ne font pas
de politique
et là d'un coup on découvre finalement
ce qu'ont découvert les italiens avec
neuf jours d'avancé
c'est vrai que le patrick mennucci on
peut se demander quand on écoute le
président de la république est ce que
ces mesures n'arrive pas un petit peu
tard c'est très difficile de se
prononcer là dessus parce que moi je ne
veux pas je ne veux pas asséner des
vérités parce que je n'ai pas l'ensemble
des informations mais il est vrai que la
courbe en tout cas celle qui montre que
le pic épidémique
on peut arriver dans les huit dix jours
tous les deux voilà voilà
et donc c'est là on la connaît depuis
longtemps il ya peut-être eu une prise
de conscience du président de la
république de la nécessité il a pensé
pendant un moment
comme d'autres dirigeants européens ou
même donald trump qui il ya quelques
jours nous expliquer que c'était moins
que la grippe
bon il a peut-être pas d'accord et donc
et à un moment il a peut-être aussi
saisi que c'était une occasion pour lui
de se révéler comme président de la
république parce que depuis qu'il est
élu ce n'est que chaos manifestation des
accords dans le pays et là c'est un
sujet où et même ceux qui le critiquent
régulièrement en gamme et une difficulté
parce que moi car des gendarmes faut que
nous fassions nation je suis d'accord
moi je suis d'accord que la france se
mobilise
je suis d'accord qu'on se bat alors
l'ennemi là il est difficile à repérer
et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
stratégie chez emmanuel macron comme
toujours d'ailleurs et que là ce soir
il a choisi la stratégie
du chef du commando il a beaucoup hésité
dans la journée il a reculé sur la
question des élections municipales et
nous verrons d'ailleurs au deuxième tour
si c'était judicieux ou pas de les
maintenir parce que si le pic épidémique
la semaine prochaine et donc pas souvent
les données de doublement aujourd'hui on
a 16 ans demain ça sera me laisse que ça
sera 2000 après demain hélas le deuxième
tour lure pourra plus l'annuler enfin je
veux dire de bois plus leurs portes et
bordeaux justement la justification en
fait la transition patrick mennucci
merci giuly qui justifie le maintien
c'est municipal après un long suspense
que nous décrivent et didier maïsto tout
au long de la journée écoutez j'ai
interrogé les scientifiques sur nos
élections municipales dont le premier
tour se tiendra dans quelques jours il
considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce que
les français
même les plus vulnérables se rendent aux
urnes j'ai aussi demandé au premier
ministre il l'a fait encore ce matin de
consulter largement toutes les familles
politiques et elles ont exprimé la même
volonté mais il conviendra de veiller au
respect strict des gestes barrières
contre le virus et des recommandations
sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous ouais mais le
maquereau qui fait confiance au civisme
alors tout en appelant effectivement les
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans les
handicapés les malades chroniques
ceux qui ont des troubles respiratoires
à rester chez eux dont moi je pense que
fait ça fait longtemps que le président
république a pas du voir bureaux de vote
qu'en
voilà il ya ça va très compliqué parce
que d'abord il ya ce qu'on me dit ce que
j'aime dans un dom dans les partis
politiques
c'est qu'il ya des difficultés
aujourd'hui de recrutement des des
assesseurs parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui
n'ont pas envie de passer la journée
d'abord déjà que c'est pas très agréable
d'entendre normal mais c'est un acte
républicain et citoyen mais là on est
dans une situation où beaucoup de gens
ont refusé d'y aller donc est ce que je
sais que beaucoup de mairies ont mis on
demandé à leurs employés communaux de se
substituer aux assesseurs
moi je pense que les gens pensent pas
tellement ou votant mais je pense que
les assesseurs qui vont rester toute la
journée dans un bureau de vote
je vois pas comment on obtient un mètre
entre le président on l'a fait apprécier
tout ça me paraît très compliqué et plus
long et compliqué le dépouillement
dépouillement qui peut parfois être un
peu comment dire animée voilà c'est
arrivé c'est pas parce qu'il ya le
coronavirus qui va pas y avoir de la
politique est parfois la politique un
peu violente dans ces moments là donc
moi je n'aurais pas été j'aurais pas été
appartement où on ferme les écoles vont
prendre ce type de mesures ça ne
m'aurait pas choqué qu'on reporte les
élections municipales
deux mois et demi ou deux mois ce n'est
pas qu'elle est reportée d'une année
mais voilà qu'est ce qu'elle est les
français ont la tête à aller voter
sega sort aussi comme plan b on a tous
envie je pense que face à des événements
comme ça de s'unir et de ne pas céder à
la polémique facile stérile sage pense
que les français comme tous les peuples
sur la terre le comprennent très bien
bon on est prêt à faire des sacrifices
et d'ailleurs les gestes lavez vous les
mains fait attention que c'était on n'a
pas attendu monsieur macron pour
s'occuper de nos anciens s'occuper bon
là il a essayé effectivement de 2,2
d'être dans cette posture là beaucoup de
dommages appuyé au personnel hospitalier
il aurait sans doute préféré qu'on les
écoute un peu plus dangereux
un peu d'argent et des et des moyens le
grand peuple français etc
c'était un discours quand même très long
un peu du verbiage dans la deuxième
partie du discours bien sûr qu'on a tous
envie de s'unir derrière une cause mais
encore faut-il qu'on ait confiance en
notre chef et le problème c'est que
monsieur macron et c'est pas offense que
de le dire est un peu quelqu'un de
versatile c'est quelqu'un en qui on n'a
pas confiance et pour être un père de la
nation il faut être soi même
incarnez un peu la figure du chef au
dessus des partis ce que ça fait cher
jacques chirac par exemple sans faire de
politique politicienne
et c'est peut-être une occasion qu'il
espère en tout cas de ce chef de ce
point de vue aujourd'hui on a encore vu
je désolé de le dire mais les
machinistes derrière l'acteur on a vu un
peu le décor on a vu la ficelle qui
pendaient et ça c'est pas terrible quoi
je dois le dire donc les français ont
envie de se reconnaître
à un moment dans un jeu dit pas un chef
mais dans une figure qui va les
rassembler parce que les événements sans
risquer d'être grave mais là on voit
quand même un peu la politique
politicienne et la salle des machines et
ça c'est pas très rassurant vous parliez
d'argent alors là manifestement l'état
va mettre clairement la main à la poche
puisque cette fermeture d'écoles
implique que book de personnes ne
pourront pas dé travailler que ça va
être pris en charge
il l'a dit il peut protéger les
entreprises emmanuel macron donc ça sera
mis ça sera pris en charge ce chômage
partiel par l'état 1 il veut un système
plus généreux est d'ailleurs que les
allemands c'est pas inquiétant par les
temps qui courent où semble-t-il les
caisses sont vides on nous le répète
elle répète tous les jours je je je fais
je crois pas qu'elle soit vide enfin
s'attendre à mettre de l'argent dans les
séries des retraites avec est soumis
depuis pour d'autres choses ne sont pas
vos la vérité c'est que ce qu aurait
atteint dès ce soir
c'est par exemple le moratoire sur les
nouvelles règles de chômage
je pense que ça se sont était quelque
chose c'est citant débat manifestants
les bains oui mais on en débat dès le
départ je n'ai pas obtenu la norme
serait toujours au milieu du gué voilà
annoncé par certains sites aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il n'a pas dit il n'a pas dit
il n'a pas dit et aussi que la la les
nouvelles règles qui rentrent en liga
ces jours ci ça va être une
précarisation de plusieurs être
excessive mais de deux ou trois cent
mille personnes immédiatement
donc là par exemple qu'il y avait un
geste à faire sans l'annuler puisque ça
a été monté mais bon on peut y avoir un
report de six mois comme il a fait un
report sur les expulsions domiciliaire
et je crois que c'est une bonne chose
mais c'est dans le même état d'esprit
mais pourquoi le faire sur les
expulsions domiciliaire est pas le faire
sur le chômage et bio moi il me semble
que la vraie question c'est est-ce
d'abandon des services publics de
l'hôpital depuis des années et que même
au moment où on tresse des louanges et à
juste titre d'ailleurs à ceux qui
combattent
dans les hôpitaux le corps d'un virus on
ne voit pas les éléments qui ferait que
ces jeunes dirais oui j'ai été reconnue
en paroles très bien merci
mais je suis aussi reconnu dans mon
travail dans le fait que j'ai de
meilleures conditions de travail plus de
jeunes pour voilà et ça ça n'a pas été
fait donc on est toujours dans la
posture mais voilà cccb l'opérateur du
président de la république alors une
petite oui oui on se rend compte chaque
fois quand même qu'à l'occasion d'une
crise ça change
les fondamentaux de de monsieur macro et
de sa majorité
parce que là il nous parle de fermeture
des frontières sans véritablement le
dire donc il dit plus de protection il
remet en cause d'une certaine mais
contient il a dit voilà il faudra que ça
soit décidée à l'échelle européenne se
déroule à y envoyer ce sujet là je
savais bien que ça veut rien dire de
reporter toujours ce à l'échelle
européenne
si vous fermez vos frontières
confirmez-vous frontières aujourd'hui et
vous allez à menton vous pouvez vous ne
pouvez pas entrer en italie vous avez
des carabinieri avec les gants etc et
toutes les précautions d'usagé
vous ne pouvez pas aller en italie mais
vous pouvez très bien aller en france
c'est une passoire aujourd'hui donc les
italiens ferme la frontière enfin pas il
faut pas céder ont repris nationalisme
enchères dit oui mais en même temps il
dit forfar nation vous voyez c'est
chaque fois qu'on met c'est bien le
problème de monsieur macron c'est que
chaque fois il y re découvre un petit
peu comme je disais et l'eau chaude que
un pays c'est aussi des frontières une
souveraineté
un système de santé des mesures qui
peuvent être protectionniste par moments
quand la situation le commande
et de rajouter toujours ces suffixes
dégradant nationalise
ce sport cumulant tiers 68 en même temps
que les écoles moi je pense que la
fermeture des frontières et le cndd en
amont fonction du pays voisins quelle
est sa politique à l'égard du corona
virus si on a une politique qu'ils
considèrent être la même que la nôtre et
qui a les mêmes les mêmes moyens
l'intérêt de la fermeture est quand même
très limité puisque les gens luttent si
il ya des pays autour de la france qui
font laisser aller sur cette question
évidemment qu'ils vont faire mais vous
le dire mais on a tellement je veux dire
je pense d'eux
ce que lily et maisto est vrai on a vu
les images tout à l'heure seshoka homos
les carabinieri d'un côté qui prennent
la température des jeunes et puis au
mode et italienne passée
d'ailleurs on ne voit pas de policiers
français et des gars y'a pas de
policiers voilà donc mais voilà elle pas
nouveau ça d'ailleurs parce que même
avant le corona virus moi qui vais
souvent dans la région là bas c'est
comme ça depuis des années oui mais ça
c'est la loi
oui c'est renoncer sans nom mais ce que
je veux dire du duo barça oui oui
visiter une prison parce que beaucoup
plus strictes quand même
de ce point de vue alors on arrive à la
deuxième partie du débat est ce qu'il y
aura un avant et un après ce qu'on peut
tirer les leçons de cette grosse crise
qui malheureusement n'est pas fini bruno
le maire a aujourd'hui a lancé un appel
d'offres déjà briques années didier
maïsto c'est pas bien c'est parce qu'ils
croient que c'est montebourg qui avait
lancé l'appel mais bon c'est un bruno le
maire notre ministre français des
finances qui appelle les multinationales
à tirer les conséquences de l'épidémie
qui a mis plusieurs usines à l'arrêt en
chiné et compliquer l'approvisionnement
d'autres pays alors ils appellent ça un
game challenger un événement qui change
la donne
sous-entendu voilà la nécessité
peut-être de relocaliser un certain
nombre d'activités à vous et je vous
entends votre réponse il est courtois là
il découvre encore là et voilà être
peut-être plus indépendants nous dit le
ministre sur un certain nombre de
chaînes de production vous applaudissez
dès demain problème c'est que capte bois
que les 80% des
des bases des médicaments sont fabriqués
en chine c'est que tu me manques comme
prendre un moment pour dire en 10 90 on
comprend que ça on peut avoir un
problème à partir d'une situation on
peut on peut aussi être l'otage de ces
pays pour des raisons politiques
y à payer à agir si on détient votre
capacité à vous soigner
c'est terrifiant et ce qui est assez
paradoxal c'est que ce soit bruno le
maire qui est le chantre de la du
libéralisme qui nous explique
aujourd'hui qu'il faut renationaliser ou
réindustrialiser sur des choses entre
nous qui sont pas très compliqué parce
que pourquoi les médicaments sont partis
en chine pour une question de prix c'est
possible bonne question est ce que le
coût du travail est
komba blocs oui mais si on a une rupture
de médicaments ses gammes des questions
je crois que le d'ailleurs bruno le
maire en tout cas ma parole a tranché
j'attends les actes c'est en écho aux
paroles non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
secteurs à la fois stratégique et à la
fois très important pour la vie
quotidienne des français qu'on a
complètement délégués pour des histoires
de coûts avec beaucoup de légèreté d'un
conséquences si vous voulez déjà coco
90% de la pénicilline qui servent à la
fabrication qui sert à la fabrication
les antibiotiques soient confiées aux
chinois c'est une folie 100% des pédales
de freins je prends un deuxième exemple
puisqu'on rendre donc ça ça a l'air de
rien mais ça bloque complètement la
production des voitures etc et on se
rend compte avec ça c'est le premier
point est le deuxième c'est la
financiarisation de l'économie avec
beaucoup de sociétés qui sont en bourse
qui qui essaie de fabriquer à pas cher
entre guillemets mais on voit que les
coûts induits et indirects sont beaucoup
plus importants au final est que quand
on voit les la privatisation des
aéroports des routes que tous nos
fleurons pour l'instant d'ailleurs voilà
pour l'instant les conditions de marché
du marché sans pas un instant pour les
conditions du marché sont pas réunies
bon et finalement on se rend compte que
tout ce qui a été exprimé par le peuple
dans la rue à l'occasion des idées jaune
ou à l'occasion des grévistes qui ont
manié on a dit un tas de noms d'oiseaux
beaucoup de méchancetés et d'adjectifs
et d'épithètes dépréciatif vis-à-vis de
ces journées ont finalement là encore on
découvre que toutes ces personnes qui
étaient dans la rue il n'y était pas
simplement pour prendre l'air mais parce
qu'elle revendiquait quelque chose de
vital de vital dans le dans la vie même
du pays et j'espère en tout cas où je
pense qu'il y aura un après parce que ça
a explosé à la face de tout le monde
parce que nous on est certain nombre à
dire vous connaissez mes positions sur
le sujet c'est pas nouveau
j'ai fait campagne contre maastricht et
c'est donc pour moi je me dis enfin mais
il n'y a pas de triomphalisme
ici au moins on peut réorienter un petit
peu remettre le curseur
on va pas faire ça du jour au lendemain
on prend que il ya une mondialisation
qui a des échanges qu'on peut pas vivre
en totale autarcie etc
mais quand même il ya cette volonté
exprimée très fortement par les français
mais par beaucoup de peuples au sein de
l'union européenne et pas beaucoup de
peuples dans le monde et cette
mondialisation un peu sauvage sans règle
avec une europe qui réglemente pour les
petits la vie quotidienne mais qui au
final des règlements et des règles la
vie des gens mais ça les français n'en
veulent plus et j'espère que les hommes
politiques en tirerons toutes les
conséquences et viendront réorienter le
modèle 1 patrick mennucci sans faire de
la grande philosophie justement même sur
un pan très spirituel philosophique est
ce que ce ce virus selon vous ah oui
mais changera peut-être tout cas c'est
la prise de conscience juge qu'il ya des
productions qui se stratégique
alors je ne dis pas qu'il faut tout
ramener en france et je peux en région
parisienne peu importe mais ya justement
l'europe et cette relocalisation
au fond c'est pas une question franco
française ça peut être une question
européenne voilà un sujet pour l'europe
où on aimerait que l'europe s'occupe de
choses comme ça dit aujourd'hui sur la
fabrication de la pénicilline
on est capable d'avoir une réserve
d'avoir des fabrications au moins de 52
personnes dans notre pays
mais vous voyez là devant vous aimez
c'est ça qu'elle devrait d'ailleurs
parce que c'est parce que si c'est le
rhum qui l'on est
ça donne un sens à l'europe aujourd'hui
on ne comprend les jeunes qui ont votre
position sur l'euro c'est parce que le
sens a disparu c'est parce qu'il ya un
an de ça si vous voulez c'est rester un
voeu pieux parce que quand on voit que
l'europe n'a pas été capable de faire
une harmonisation fiscale sociale mais à
minima un minimum donc vous avez vous
assisté à du dumping social et fiscal au
sein même une compétition délétère au
sein même de l'europe
on parle de compétition intra
européennes mais si vous voulez si vous
fabriquez si vous vendez
vous planter des tomates par exemple
marché mondial où la chine est
d'ailleurs assez puissante
ça coûte trois fois moins les tomates
les fruits les légumes ou là où l'avion
en espagne vous faites comment à partir
de ça et si vous avez une entreprise que
vous l'a localisé en irlande où dans
d'autres pays
vous faites comment on pouvait pas avoir
une europe qui parle du manhwa donc
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est pas du
repli c'est reprend un peu retrouvé la
bonne entité qui permette au peuple de
reprendre en main leur destinée
on a longtemps pensé pas moi mais
beaucoup de l'an qu'elle était
européenne cette destinée et aujourd'hui
on voit qu'elle est plutôt nationale
puisque qu'on voit que quand il ya une
crise on en appelle à la nation refaire
nation parce que l'europe était absente
est complètement paralysée j'ajoute que
ses créateurs d'impôts parce que si on
regarde quels sont les productions qui
sont nécessaires à la vie de la société
et qu'on décide donc ça peut être une
plante qui décidez alors qu'il soit
européen ou national
mais ça permettra effectivement de
recréer des emplois sur le territoire
national mais tout à l'heure je
présentais quand vous parliez de lemaire
montebourg mais veut beau mot là c'est
des choses que kddi arnaud depuis
longtemps et qui n'ont jamais été écouté
par personne n'y a pas plus d'ailleurs
parfois de son volant d'un coupé
merci à tous les deux didier maïsto
inouïe d'avoir été
avec nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
donald trump est à l'affût de 5
milliards enfin en tout cas preuve pour
une première tranche de travaux dont la
barrière n'est pas totalement construite
la totalité de la frontière c'est plus
de 3000 km le président des états unis
reprend le discours qu'il avait comme
candidats présentant les migrants comme
des vecteurs de délinquance de
criminalité le trafic de drogue
il est certain que la majorité des
migrants et mexicains ou centres
américains qui sont aux etats-unis ne
sommes pas là pour faire du trafic de
drogue mais pour travailler
il ya une première chose que je pense
qui est importante c'est que les états
que ce soit la france ou la belgique
reconnaissent cette situation reconnaît
ce qui a eu des adoptions illégales cela
concernait combien d'enfants
les chiffres exacts ne sont pas très
clair mais plusieurs centaines donc
vraiment c'est et orchestré au plus haut
niveau en fait ce trafic d'enfants donc
vous avez été d'ailleurs toutes deux
victimes
j'ai par owni l'amour que j'ai reçu de
mes parents adoptifs je sens que cette
adoption n'est pas totalement légale
quoi pour vous vous étiez adopté de
manière tout à fait la cour à tout est
légal j'espère du fond du coeur que
notre procédure aboutira qu'un
concurrent se passionnera pour notre
histoire on espère être les pionniers en
la matière parce qu'il ya d'autres pays
qui sont concernés donc on espère
pouvoir ouvrir la porte aux institutions
européennes finalement
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette merde
l'année dernière la quantité de drogue
saisie a augmenté d'environ 490 m
et on m'a arrêté en pensant que j'étais
membre d'un gang
j'étais suspecté de 10 ici la plupart de
femmes courageux très longues peines de
prison 20 minutes donc nous avons
inventé ce concours pour le remonter un
peu le moral je vais certes indiqué je
suis déterminé à remporter le titre miss
talavera brute
[Musique]
emmanuel macron s'est adressé aux
français il est à deux heures une
allocution de plus de vingt minutes
durant laquelle résident la république
et annoncé plusieurs mesures
la fermeture des écoles et des
universités dès lundi la limitation des
déplacements pour l'ensemble des
français
les personnes âgées celles qui souffrent
de maladies chroniques sont invités à
rester chez elle
les municipales en revanche auront bien
lieu
l'épidémie de poids en habit ruse qui
s'étend dans toute l'europe italie a
dépassé le k2 1000 morts le royaume-uni
évoquent entre cinq et dix mille
personnes infectées l'allemagne en place
des contrôles à la frontière avec la
france aux états unis donald trump ferme
des portes aux étrangers venant d'europe
pour 30 jours
les marchés ont cédé nouvelle fois à la
panique aujourd'hui les annonces de la
bce n'auront pas rassuré conséquente et
débâcle historique à paris londres
francfort et wall street sont vraies se
reprend légèrement le cac 40 a clôturé à
- 12,28 %
[Musique]
et
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france le coronavirus est la plus grave
crise sanitaire qui est connue la france
depuis un siècle
ce sont les mots ce soir d'emmanuel
macron lors de son discours télévisé le
président qui a pris la parole pendant
une vingtaine de minutes pour expliquer
la gestion par la france de l'épidémie
pour en parler on retrouve notre
reporter lit la femme ouzou devant
l'elysée j'ai connu la locution qui
était très attendu emmanuel macron a
voulu se montrer rassurant même si il a
pris l'ampleur de la crise à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés
le chef de l'état a expliqué qu'il avait
consulté les plus grands experts avant
de prendre les décisions qu'il a annoncé
ce soir parmi ces décisions
il a demandé à ce que toutes les
personnes de plus de 70 ans restent
autant que possible chez elles
il a aussi annoncé la fermeture des
établissements scolaires et
universitaires
dès lundi je propose de l'écouter dès
lundi et jusqu'à nouvel ordre les
crèches les écoles les collèges les
lycées et les universités seront fermés
pour une raison simple nos enfants et
nos plus jeunes selon les scientifiques
toujours sont celles et ceux qui
propagent semble-t-il le plus rapidement
le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir de
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation pour que en effet
les personnels qui sont indispensables à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire puisse
faire garder leurs enfants et continuer
d'aller au travail pour vous protéger
vous soigner et donc cette organisation
sera travaillée par le gouvernement dans
les prochains jours avec l'ensemble des
élus et tous les responsables sur nos
territoires
alors la question était de savoir si les
élections municipales seraient reportées
elles auront bien le bien lieu c'est la
décision
du chef de l'état qui a expliqué que
rien ne s'oppose à ce que les français
aillent aux urnes
il a consulté les différents partis
gérard larcher aussi le président du
sénat est donc les élections municipales
auront lieu écouter emmanuel macron j'ai
interrogé les scientifiques sur nos
élections municipales dont le premier
tour se tiendra dans quelques jours il
considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce que
les français même les plus vulnérables
se rendent aux urnes
j'ai aussi demandé au premier ministre
il l'a fait encore ce matin de consulter
largement toutes les familles politiques
et elles ont exprimé la même volonté
mais il conviendra de veiller au respect
strict des gestes barrières contre le
virus et des recommandations sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous alors la question
avant cette allocution du chef de l'état
était de savoir si la france était prête
à affronter cette crise si des hôpitaux
français était prêt à affronter cette
crise et il semble ce soir qu emmanuel
macron ait voulu répondre oui à ces
questions le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer a
détaillé les mesures annoncées par le
président a coûté depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines nous avons mis en
place les mécanismes de continuité
administrative et de continuité
pédagogique surtout puisque notre but
c'est évidemment que aucun élève ne
reste au bord du chemin dans une période
exceptionnelle comme celle ci la france
a des atouts en matière d'enseignement à
distance
elle a une institution qui s'appelle le
cned depuis fort longtemps qui est
préparé pour cela et depuis plusieurs
mois nous avons préparé cette
institution pour donner des cours à
distance en appui au travail que les
professeurs font ils le font souvent au
travers des environnements numériques de
travail qui existe plutôt dans les
collèges et des lycées et nous allons
donc avoir grâce au cned ce mécanisme
que nous appelons la classe à la maison
qui permet d'avoir à la fois et classes
virtuelles et des ressources
pédagogiques pour tous les enfants
devraient fermer les établissements
scolaires une mesure appropriée selon
gilles casanova consultant en stratégie
communication sécurisé 800 membres de
l'académie de médecine et c'était tout
de nos invités
je pense que c'est une mesure courageuse
les enfants effectivement comme cela
vient d'être audi sont de grands
transmetteur des virus respiratoires
lorsqu'est les infections respiratoires
c'est paru qu'il circule c'est parce
qu'ils passent aux générations supérieur
parents grands parents les enfants sont
très mobiles puisque non seulement ils
vont en classe mais ils ont des
activités parascolaires donc ils se
déplacent beaucoup et ils ont
effectivement des contacts très
rapprochés ils n'ont pas le réflexe que
n'ont pas d'ailleurs toujours les
adultes de se laver régulièrement les
mains d'avoir des gestes d'hygiène
élémentaires donc on sait très bien on
le sait pour la grippe ans et pour
d'autres virose que les enfants sont de
grands transmetteur donc cette décision
elle est logique
elle est courageuse moi je crois que
cette prise de parole par le président
de la république marquent un tournant et
on est enfin dans une phase de
clarification
on est en face d'un d'une situation d'un
modèle inédit qui demande une réaction
inédite de ce point de vue les autorités
françaises avait très mal commencé
le premier conseil extraordinaire sur le
coronavirus s'était terminée par
l'annoncé du 49-3 sur les retraites ce
qui du point de vue de la crédibilité de
la volonté de faire barrage à ce virus
et ne pas de l'utiliser de manière
politicienne avait été quelque chose de
terrible je pense que aujourd'hui si
l'on écoute le discours d' emmanuel
macron il a compris qu'il ne fallait
plus laisser le moindre doute sur ce
sujet et donald trump qui fait trembler
les marchés boursiers dès demain minuit
il ne sera plus possible pour les
européens d'entrée sur le territoire
américain dû rentrer
jour une mesure draconienne pour faire
face à cette émis des billets de cette
épidémie de coronavirus dans le monde
le président américain a annoncé la nuit
dernière en pointant du doigt l'europe
évoquant un virus étrangers solenzara
interdiction d'entrée à partir de
vendredi plus aucun voyageur venant
d'europe ne pourra mettre un pied aux
etats unis une décision du président
américain pour limiter la propagation du
coronavirus pour éviter que de nouveaux
cas n'entre dans notre pays nous allons
suspendre tous les voyages de l'europe
vers les états unis pendant les 30
prochains jours
les nouvelles règles entrant en vigueur
vendredi à minuit ces restrictions
seront adaptés en fonction des
conditions sur le terrain
cette mesure s'applique à toute personne
ayant séjourné dans l'espace schengen
ses 14 derniers jours exception faite
des citoyens américains et des résidents
permanents les américains d'ailleurs
invités à éviter tout voyage à
l'étranger
une annonce qui fait bondir les
dirigeants européens et le coronel et
luce est une crise mondiale qui n'est
pas limitée à un continent action
l'union européenne désapprouvent le fait
que la décision des états unis d'imposer
une interdiction de voyage s'était
éprise de façon unilatérale et sans
consultation
quant au tfc l'union des forces pour
limiter la propagation du virus
côté français le secrétaire d'état
chargé des transports appelle à la
coopération européenne
je connais le tempérament de donald
trump qui a réagit d'ailleurs peut-être
un peu plus tard que certains autres
pays notamment les pays européens sur le
sujet il prend aujourd'hui des mesures
assez drastiques sur l'espace schengen
que nous aurons évidemment à évaluer et
je le redis ça nécessite d'autant plus
la coordination européenne autour du
président de la république une décision
américaine qui furent prend aussi part c
ces options en effet les frontières
restent ouvertes aux britanniques
pour autant le royaume louis désapprouve
voulu aussi cette mesure nous ne pensons
pas que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
d'après les conseils que nous recevons
il n'est pas prouvé que des
interventions telles que des
interdictions de voyager est un effet
matériel cette décision prendra effet
vendredi soir mais elle a d'ores et déjà
des conséquences
l'annnonce de donald trump a précipité
l'effondrement des bourses
alors pourquoi une telle mesure écoutez
l'analyse de jean eric branaa maître de
conférences en politique américaine
la crise est montée très très fort
donald trump a essayé de temporiser mais
en même temps quand il interdit aux
européens de venir
ce n'est pas en portant le blâme sur les
européens particulièrement le blâme il
est porté plus largement ce que rappelle
donald trump c'est que les voyages ont
été interdits avec la chine t et la fin
janvier et que les européens n'ont pas
pris la même mesure c'est plutôt là
dessus qu'il vise un petit peu les
européens en disant écoutez vous avez
laissé rentrer le virus en europe sans
vous occupez de sécuriser vos frontières
désormais nous on va sécuriser les
autres parce qu'il faut vraiment que le
virus ne se propage pas trop vite et
marchés financiers ont cédé à la panique
aujourd'hui londres francfort madrid ont
décroché en début d'après midi la bourse
de paris qui connaît est la plus forte
chute de son histoire et ce malgré les
mesures prises par la banque centrale
européenne pour soutenir les économies
le président de l'institution christine
lagarde parle d'un choc majeur et plaide
pour une réponse coordonnée la
propagation du coroner virus qu'ovide 19
a été un choc majeur pour les
perspectives de croissance de l'économie
mondiale et de l'économie de la zone
euro
elle a accentué la volatilité des
marchés même si elle est finalement
temporaires par nature elle aura un
impact important sur l'activité
économique notamment ralentissant la
production en raison de la rupture des
chaînes d'approvisionnement et en
réduisant la demande intérieure et
étrangère et pour l'économiste olivier
de la marche que l'on retrouve dans ses
cages sur rt france la bce fait fausse
route tout comme les dirigeants mondiaux
qui ne vont pas assez loin la france en
première ligne aujourd'hui dans dans le
système actuel avec les fonds de pension
avec les fonds de retraite tout est basé
sur les marchés financiers si vous
laissez les marchés financiers
s'écrouler ça veut dire que vous payez
plus les retraites aux fonctionnaires
que et ça me paraît un peu compliquée
donc
aujourd'hui on a l'impression tout de
même alors en france qui ne se passe
rien et j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
absolument aucune intention de bouger
quoi que ce soit
on est le seul pays européens d'ailleurs
à prendre de mesures le res prend des
mesures mais de toute façon c'est pas le
c'est pas le problème du cornaro virus
le corps navires us c'est un catalyseur
et c'est un révélateur d'une situation
qui n'a jamais été réglé depuis 2008 on
a mis la poussière sous le tapis
le coronavirus arrive la poussière
ressort de tout appui le dessous le
tapis est la chute des cotations
boursières se sont d'ailleurs ne sont
pas d'ailleurs les seules conséquences
de la pandémie due coronavirus la
production économique des pays touchés
et menacé et le risque d'un emballement
de la crise financière et réelle les
explications de guillaume un rossi il ne
fait décidément pas bon être trader ces
jours ci les market makers hurle dans le
pit tout le monde tente de fermer ses
positions et dans les fonds les niveaux
de value at risk sont déclenchés en
clair les bourses du monde entier sont
en pleine panique et l'europe ne fait
pas exception
ce jeudi le cac 40 avait perdu 29%
depuis le 19 février dernier
idem pour le dax est l'équivalent
allemand du cac 40 qui a perdu plus de
24%
même chose en italie bien sûr parce que
30% depuis trois semaines et plus de 21%
pour le footsie britannique
et si les responsables politiques et des
principales institutions européennes
s'inquiètent c'est que les courbes que
vous venez de voir en rappelle d'autres
un peu plus anciennes voici à nouveau la
cotation du cac 40 vous voyez là aussi
une chute sévère de l' indice
sauf qu'il s'agit cette fois des cours
de 2008 en pleine crise financière un
épisode dont les économies du globe ne
se sont toujours pas complètement remise
et malheureusement les annonces de la
bce ont clairement échoué à rassurer les
marchés les bourses de paris londres ou
encore milan on plongé encore un peu
plus après que francfort a déclaré
vouloir maintenir ses taux directeurs la
bce qui a pourtant également annoncé un
programme de prêts pour les pme les plus
touchés par le coronavirus ainsi qu'à
rachat de 120 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires de dette publique et
privée pour cette année
et les états ne sont d'ailleurs pas en
reste l'italie compte débloquer 25
milliards d'euros pour lutter contre le
coc vide 19
le royaume uni a lui aussi annoncé son
plan de 34 milliards et d'autres pays
d'europe ont pris des mesures censés
soulager leurs économies chaque état y
va de son initiative particulière et
c'est bien le problème
les états du vieux continent n'ont pas
encore pris de réelles actions
financières d'envergure coordonner ce
qui a d'ailleurs provoqué la colère de
la patronne de la bce
christine lagarde qui a dénoncé je cite
la complaisance et la lenteur des
dirigeants en particulier en zone euro
et pourtant le danger est réel
au delà de la crise sanitaire l'économie
mondiale semble bien être un tournant
car avec les quarantaine et les
fermetures de frontières l'économie
tourne de plus en plus au ralenti
les pme sont les plus touchés notamment
celles liées au tourisme
or ces pme ont peu de trésorerie et
risque bien de se retrouver en cessation
de paiement avec des prêts non
remboursés ce qui affole à juste titre
les marchés des marchés en berne cela
signifie également moins de capacité de
financement pour les plus grosses
entreprises qui voient également leur
capitalisation fondre au rythme de la
chute boursière des banques qui à la fin
ne se prêtent plus entre elles et se
retrouve à court de liquidités bref tout
ceci est connu les crises économiques et
financières s'auto alimente
et alors que lieu survit grâce à la
politique généreuse de la bce depuis la
dernière crise
le coronavirus légué par la chauve
souris pourrait bien être le cygne noir
de cette décennie qui commence à peine
un signe dont le chant accompagne une
nouvelle récession économique et
d'italie premier foyer du coronavirus en
europe a franchi la barre des douze
mille cas de contamination plus de 827
personnes sont mortes le pays est
entièrement confinée pour le troisième
jour consécutif et des mesures se
renforce encore le récit de rania
berrada avec françois tyszkiewicz à
partir de ce jeudi matin tous les
commerces du pays sont désormais fermés
sauf ceux des secteurs de la
distribution alimentaire et de la santé
nous fermons les magasins les bars les
pubs et les restaurants et nous laissons
la possibilité de faire des livraisons à
domicile
nous fermons aussi les coiffeurs les
salons de beauté les services de cantine
qui ne peuvent pas garantir la distance
de sécurité
pour ce qui concerne l'activité
productive et les activités
il faut favoriser le télétravail les
vacances la prise de congés payés des
employés de nouvelles mesures alors que
depuis mardi c'est l'ensemble de
l'italie qui est placé en confinement
tous les italiens doivent éviter les
déplacements sauf pour aller travailler
sur ravitailler ou pour soins médicaux
mais difficile de respecter les
consignes à naples ils étaient plusieurs
centaines ce mercredi a défié les
interdictions de sortie
la recommandation est bien sûr de rester
chez soi mais comment est-ce possible de
rester 24 heures sur 24 à la maison
c'est impossible
je crois que si on crée pas de choses en
cours on ne rassemble pas de foule
on peut au moins nous laisser sortir
pour un footing personne ne m'attend
c'est le soleil et la mer qui nous
incite peut-être à sortir déjà on
commence à être nostalgique de la vie
d'avant sincèrement j'ai juste voulu
faire une petite promenade rien d'autre
sans exagérer bien sûr on est inquiet
mais il ya beaucoup d'espoir que tout se
résolvent nous savons que tout ça dépend
aussi de nous et surtout de notre façon
de nous comporter un peu plus au nord à
rome
les tories se sont fait rares dans les
rues du centre de la capitale
une situation qui ne devrait pas
s'arranger dans les prochains jours une
flopée de compagnies aériennes ont
annoncé suspendre leurs liaisons avec
l'italie
parmi elles air france ryanair et
easyjet et british airways au sol les
restrictions sont aussi de rigueur
l'autriche a procédé ce mercredi à la
quasi fermeture de sa frontière
les automobilistes en provenance
d'italie doivent désormais présenter un
certificat médical
même chose à la frontière avec la
slovénie
il faut dire que l'épidémie se propage
de façon alarmante en italie deuxième
foyer de l'épidémie dans le monde pour
faire face à l'urgence sanitaire du cp
compter annoncé une enveloppe de
plusieurs milliards d'euros et
habillement à peine un délit bella tôt
nous venons d'approuver la location
d'une somme extraordinaire de 25
milliards d'euros et nous sommes
conscients des difficultés auxquelles le
pays est confronté dans cette situation
d'urgence
à noter également que tous les
événements sportifs nationaux dont le
championnat de football sont suspendus
des mesures drastiques qui doivent
rester en vigueur au moins jusqu'au 3
avril
le premier ministre italien promet les
premiers effets de ce grand effort
d'ici une quinzaine de jours est la
journaliste olivier goujon qui vit en
italie dans la ville de milan ont filmé
nous raconte comment cette vie
s'organise au quotidien on peut sortir
il s'agit de sortir avec une ce qu'on
appelle une auto certification c'est à
dire que on certifie on promet consorts
pour un bon motif
donc on peut sortir pour faire des
courses mais l'essentiel parce que
d'occupation les magasins sont fermés
on peut sortir pour raisons de santé
c'est à dire se rendre à des
consultations par exemple ou pour des
raisons urgentes
on peut également s'y pour une bonne
raison encore une fois voyager les bars
les discothèques les restaurants tout
est fermé les magasins un peu plus en
plus car de shopping donc ya pas
vraiment non plus de raison de sortir en
sorte pour l'essentiel certaines
pharmacies ont mis en place un système
de guichet avec des files d'attentes
les supermarchés sont ouverts également
de manière un petit peu fractionné ont
fait la queue dehors en respectant une
distance d'un mètre ou d'un mètre
cinquante
et puis à l'intérieur on fait rentrer
les gens 5 par 5 10 par 10 20 par wasa
dépend de la taille d'un des magasins
globalement l'italie réagit très bien
les gens
sont solidaires ils sont responsables et
assume globalement un comportement très
digne et autres conséquences en europe
les contrôles sont renforcés à la
frontière entre la france et l'allemagne
depuis cet après midi c'est notamment le
cas en moselle et dans les deux
départements alsaciens les policiers
tellement contrôler tous les
automobilistes et piétons
hier l'allemagne avait passé de grand
est comme une région à risques
berlin qui demande aussi aux
travailleurs français de ne pas venir en
allemagne et pour une riche bruckner
analyse politique l'allemagne est
parfaitement consciente qu'elle pourrait
connaître une augmentation des cas sur
son territoire thurman et l allemagne
prend la menace au sérieux
t'as ton actuellement c'est que le
développement de la pandémie évolué
différemment d'un pays à l'autre en
photographie en logan cup
lorsque vous regardez les courbes la
quasi explosion dans certains pays comme
en corée ou en italie ce produit tout
simplement plus rapidement que dans
d'autres pays et l'allemagne est
consciente que cela peut également se
produire ici simple fait que les
chiffres sont inférieurs à ceux d'autres
pays ne signifie pas que cela ne se
produira pas ramené à lever nous
devrions idéalement essayer de le
ralentir mais nous ne pouvons pas la
respecte
the wall street la pire chose que nous
puissions faire à ce stade et de se
blâmer les uns les autres de désigner un
pays qui serait davantage responsables
qu'ils n'agiraient pas correctement ce
taux edwards chaume devons tous faire
notre possible et idéalement bien nous
coordonner ce qui est primordial
notamment dans la région frontalière et
je suis tout à fait convaincu qu'un ou 3
est également une solution
l'amérique du sud est le dernier
continent touché alors comment les pays
font qu'il pour enrayer l'épidémie des
précisions de grâce d'ailleurs avec
hélène d'un masque plus de 10 pays
touchés avec le brésil en premier plan
des centaines de cas confirmés c'est
encore peu comparé à l'europe mais des
mesures drastiques ont été prises pour
prévenir un scénario à l'italienne
les allemands à domicile
et imposer à toute personne entrant dans
le pays depuis l'italie l'espagne la
france et la chine pour une période de
14 jours a pu noter de son départ de ces
pays
nous allons déclarer l'urgence sanitaire
et le faire en conformité avec les
directives de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé publique
tous les événements publics de plus de
cinq cents personnes sont annulés quel
est le venezuela a suspendu ses vols
depuis l'europe et la colombie pour un
mois tandis que le chili l'argentine le
pérou la colombie l'équateur annonce la
mise en quarantaine des personnes en
provenance des pays les plus touchés
comme la chine l'italie l'espagne et la
france
le salvador de son côté a pris une
décision radicale
aucune entrée d'étrangers sur son
territoires et le guatemala ferme ses
portes aux personnes en provenance des
zones touchées
les écoles seront temporairement fermés
au pérou au panama au paraguay et au
salvador
la cour interaméricaine des droits de
l'homme qui siège au costa rica a
également suspendu ses audiences
publiques toute la semaine prochaine des
mesures fortes mais indispensable
d'autant que le continent n'est pas prêt
à affronter une telle crise selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
seuls trois pays dépasse la moyenne
mondiale de lit d'hôpital par habitant
cuba l'argentine et l'uruguay
même chose en matière d'équipement au
venezuela
53% des hôpitaux sont dépourvus de
masques et 90 % des établissements
hospitaliers ne dispose pas de protocole
pour les patients atteints de maladies
respiratoires transmissibles aucun ne
possède de zone d'isolement au niveau
des mesures d'hygiène les plus
élémentaires
seuls 9% des pays d'amérique latine ont
un accès continu à l'eau des problèmes
budgétaires et sanitaires de taille qui
pourrait devenir de véritables entraves
à l'éradication de l'épidémie sur le
continent
retour en france avec les municipales
emmanuel macron l'annoncé tout à l'heure
les élections auront bien lieu malgré la
crise du coronavirus les candidats
maintiennent donc leur campagne
électorale
à trois jours du premier tour antonio
duarte co fondateur de l'union des
démocrates et écologistes s'est exprimé
on écoute chaque commune chaque
intercommunalité chaque territoire
un des leviers très important pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique de végétalisation de
bâtiments à énergie passive de
transports propres
c'est le principal enjeu des municipales
et de son côté emmanuel dupuy secrétaire
national chargé des questions
internationales pour les centristes
estiment que la force de son parti et
d'être ancré dans le territoire
l'un forces politiques du centrisme
c'est d'être présent sur l'ensemble des
territoires avec des candidats dans les
toutes les communes et c'est ce qui
caractérise un petit peu l'ancrage du
centrisme dans la vie politique
française
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite retrouvé
l'autre match sur le grégory petitjean
qui s'intéresse ce soir au coronavirus
lui aussi et ses répercussions dans le
monde du sport excellente fin de soirée
at-on su rt france
[Musique]
il ya une première chose que je pense
qui est importante c'est que les états
que ce soit la france ou la belgique
reconnaissent cette situation reconnaît
ce qui a eu des adoptions illégales ça
concernait combien d'enfants
les chiffres exacts ne sont pas très
clair mais plusieurs centaines donc
vraiment été orchestrée au plus haut
niveau en fait ce trafic d'enfants dont
vous avez été d'ailleurs toutes deux
victimes
j'ai par owni l'amour que j'ai reçu de
mes parents adoptifs je sens que cette
adoption